OKAY, WE ARE READY. WE ARE
OFFICIALLY COMING TO ORDER NOW.
THIS IS THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS. GOOD MORNING. AND
WELCOME. WE HAVE 12 MEASURES ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY. WE DON'T QUITE
HAVE A QUORUM, BUT WE DO HAVE
TWO MEMBERS. SO WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR. SO WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. AND WE
INVITE YOU TO COME FORWARD. THIS
IS AB 270 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE. AND YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
MEASURE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR
. AND MEMBERS, THIS BILL
PROVIDES VOTERS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REMOVE THE CURRENT
PROHIBITION ON PUBLIC FINANCING
OF CAMPAIGNS IN CALIFORNIA
DURING THE NOVEMBER 2026 BALLOT.
SINCE 1988, PUBLIC FINANCING OF
CAMPAIGNS HAS BEEN PROHIBITED
PROHIBITED IN CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS OTHER THAN CHARTER
CITIES. FIVE CHARTER CITIES
TODAY ACTIVELY HAVE PUBLIC
FINANCING OF CAMPAIGNS, WHICH
INCLUDE THE CITIES OF BERKELEY,
LONG BEACH, LOS ANGELES,
OAKLAND, AND SAN FRANCISCO, AND
THESE CHARTER CITIES. VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY APPROVED PUBLIC
FINANCING MEASURES BECAUSE THEY
DESIRE AN ALTERNATIVE, MORE
EQUITABLE FUND RAISING SYSTEM.
THE FORTHCOMING AMENDMENTS WILL
MOVE THE PROPOSED BALLOT MEASURE
TO THE NOVEMBER 2026 BALLOT,
WHILE SPECIFYING BASIC
REQUIREMENTS OF PUBLIC FINANCING
SYSTEMS, AND CANDIDATES USING
PUBLIC FUNDING MUST FOLLOW THE
FOLLOWING. PUBLIC FINANCING
SYSTEMS MAY NOT USE FUNDS THAT
ARE EARMARKED FOR EDUCATION,
TRANSPORTATION, OR PUBLIC
SAFETY, OR REQUIRE THE VOLUNTARY
PARTICIPATION IT REQUIRE THAT
VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATING PUBLIC
FUNDING CANDIDATES ABIDE BY
EXPENDITURE LIMITS. IT WILL
REQUIRE THAT CANDIDATES MEET
STRICT CRITERIA TO QUALIFY, SUCH
AS REQUIRING THAT THEY MUST
RECEIVE SMALL DOLLAR
CONTRIBUTIONS OR VOUCHERS FROM A
SPECIFIED NUMBER OF ADULT
RESIDENTS. IT WILL BAR THE USE
OF PUBLIC FUNDS TO PAY FOR LEGAL
DEFENSES, FINES, OR REPAYMENTS
OF PERSONAL LOANS. THE CANDIDATE
CAMPAIGNS, AND IT SAYS THAT
PUBLIC FUNDING SYSTEMS SHALL NOT
DISCRIMINATE BASED ON PARTY OR
ACCORDING TO WHETHER A CANDIDATE
IS IN A CHALLENGER OR AN
INCUMBENT. TOGETHER, THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS WILL PROTECT
TAXPAYERS AND MAXIMIZE THE
BENEFIT OF QUALIFIED CANDIDATES
AND VOTERS. PUBLIC FINANCING OF
CAMPAIGNS IS THE BEST WAY TO
EMPOWER VOTERS. INCREASE
DIVERSITY OF CANDIDATES RUNNING
FOR OFFICE, AND GIVE VOTERS
CONFIDENCE THAT BIG MONEY CAN'T
JUST BUY THEIR ELECTIONS. BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY, THIS EFFORT IN
CALIFORNIA IS ABOUT RESTORING
LOCAL CONTROL FOR JURISDICTIONS
TO DECIDE WHAT ELECTORAL FUNDING
SYSTEM BEST WORKS FOR LOCALITY
AB TWO AB 270 DOES NOT REQUIRE
OR INSTITUTE PUBLIC FINANCING
ANYWHERE. IT JUST PROVIDES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MORE AUTONOMY TO
DECIDE WHAT IS BEST FOR THEM. IT
IS TIME WE PROVIDE VOTERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DECIDE WHETHER WE
REMOVE THE PROHIBITION ON A
PROVEN CAMPAIGN FINANCING SYSTEM
THAT EMPOWERS EVERYDAY VOTERS.
AND I'M GOING TO BE RESPECTFULLY
URGING YOUR AYE VOTE WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. TODAY, I AM
PLEASED TO BE JOINED BY MY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THAT'S
TRENT LANG, THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN, AND PEDRO
HERNANDEZ, THE LEGAL AND POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRENT LANG, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN. WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB 270 AND ARE VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE FOR
AUTHORING IT AND FOR THE WORK OF
THIS COMMITTEE. VOTERS ARE
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROBLEM OF MONEY IN POLITICS,
AND A POLL WE CONDUCTED IN
MARCH, 81% OF LIKELY VOTERS SAID
BIG MONEY CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTORS
HAD TOO MUCH INFLUENCE OVER
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN CALIFORNIA,
AND 63% SAID ORDINARY VOTERS HAD
TOO LITTLE INFLUENCE. AB 270
ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM THE SAME
WAY THAT SB 24 THAT THIS
COMMITTEE PREVIOUSLY PASSED
WILL, BY PLACING THE CALIFORNIA
FAIR ELECTIONS ACT ON THE
NOVEMBER 2024 BALLOT TO GIVE
EVERY CITY, COUNTY, DISTRICT AND
THE STATE THE ABILITY TO PASS
PUBLIC FUNDING OF CAMPAIGNS TO
EMPOWER VOTERS THAT CHARTER
CITIES CURRENTLY HAVE SOME
OPPOSED TO THIS IDEA HAVE
REFERENCED HOW VOTERS REJECTED
THE SAME QUESTION 14 YEARS AGO,
BUT THIS IS A DIFFERENT MEASURE.
PROP 15, IN 2010 SIMPLY REPEALED
THE BAN ON PUBLIC FUNDING
CAMPAIGNS, WHICH OPPONENTS
ATTACKED BECAUSE THERE WERE NO
RESTRICTIONS ON HOW LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS MIGHT USE
THEM. THE MEASURE, AB 270, WILL
PLACE ON THE BALLOT, ON THE
OTHER HAND, WILL ENSURE THAT
PUBLIC FUNDING SYSTEMS PROTECT
TAXPAYERS AND MAXIMIZE THE
BENEFIT TO VOTERS BY BANNING
DISCRIMINATION. DISCRIMINATION
BASED ON PARTY OR INCUMBENCY,
REQUIRING VOLUNTARILY
PARTICIPATING CANDIDATES TO
ABIDE BY EXPENDITURE LIMITS AND
MEET STRICT CRITERIA TO QUALIFY,
AND BY PLACING LIMITS ON WHAT
PUBLIC FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR.
SINCE 2010, WE HAVE SEEN VOTERS
IN CHARTER CITIES EXPRESS
IMMENSE SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC
FINANCING. IN 2011, MEASURE H IN
LOS ANGELES PASSED WITH 75% OF
THE VOTE. IN 2016, MEASURE X1 IN
BERKELEY PASSED WITH 65% OF THE
VOTE, AND JUST IN 2022, OAKLAND
PASSED MEASURE W WITH 74% OF THE
VOTE. IT'S TIME TO RETURN LOCAL
CONTROL TO EVERY JURISDICTION,
SO THEY HAVE THE SAME RIGHT THAT
CHARTER CITIES DO TO EXPLORE
THESE IMPORTANT CAMPAIGN FINANCE
OPTIONS. AND WITH THAT, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS BETH HERNANDEZ. I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE. WE'RE HAPPY TO BE
JOINING AS CO-SPONSORS OF AB 270
AT COMMON CAUSE. WE WORK TO
BUILD A MORE INCLUSIVE AND
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY, WHICH
EMPOWERS EVERYDAY PEOPLE TO HAVE
A REAL IMPACT ON THE DECISIONS
AND POLICIES THAT AFFECT US ALL,
AB 270 WOULD END THE STATE BAN
ON PUBLIC FINANCING FOR
ELECTIONS AND TAKE A STEP
FORWARD IN MAKING OUR STATE'S
ELECTORAL SYSTEM ONE THAT WORKS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT OUR
COLLECTIVE EFFORT TO GET THIS
MEASURE PLACED ON THE BALLOT IN
2026. AS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
WORKS CLOSELY WITH COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE, WE SEE HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE ALIENATED AND
TURNED OFF. BY THE WAY, OUR
CAMPAIGN FINANCE SYSTEM
CURRENTLY WORKS. RIGHT OR WRONG,
IT CAUSES A SENSE THAT YOU CAN
ONLY WIN IF YOU ARE WEALTHY,
HAVE FRIENDS WITH DEEP POCKETS,
OR ARE WILLING TO TAKE BIG
CHECKS FROM SPECIAL INTERESTS.
THIS TURNS OFF SO MANY IN WHAT
IS ALREADY A DIFFICULT MOMENT IN
OUR DEMOCRACY. BUT A SMALL
DOLLAR PUBLIC FINANCING PROGRAM
CAN HELP CHANGE THIS TREND.
THESE PROGRAMS BRING A BROADER
AND MORE DIVERSE GROUP OF PEOPLE
OUT TO DONATE TO VOTE, AND
ULTIMATELY EVEN RUN FOR OFFICE.
IF WE WANT OUR ELECTIONS TO
FULLY REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA, WE NEED A CAMPAIGN
FINANCE SYSTEM THAT DOES THE
SAME. WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING TO
IMPLEMENT OR PASS SMALL DOLLAR
PUBLIC FINANCE PROGRAMS IN
OAKLAND, SAN JOSE, SAN DIEGO AND
OTHER CITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT THIS SHOULD BE POSSIBLE
EVERYWHERE, INCLUDING STATE
ELECTIONS, NOT JUST IN OUR
CHARTER CITIES. AB 270 WILL HELP
MAKE THIS POSSIBLE. WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE, THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP. THIS
COMMITTEE, AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WELL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO BOTH LEAD WITNESSES
WHO ARE HERE TODAY. IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT?
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO, YOU MAY
COME FORWARD AND SAY JUST YOUR
NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION THAT
YOU ARE AFFILIATED WITH AND THAT
YOU SUPPORT THE BILL. YES. RIGHT
THERE. MY NAME IS CRAIG. I'M
FROM SAN JOSE. WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS CAROL CROSS. I'M FROM REDWOOD
CITY, AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MELISSA LIEB. I'M
FROM MOUNTAIN VIEW AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. OUT OF THE WAY. I'M
ALAN BRINKER FROM SUNNYVALE, AND
I AM. MOTHS TO DRY. I'M IN FAVOR
OF THIS. I'M ELSA SCHAEFER. I AM
FROM MENLO PARK. I REPRESENT THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY DEMOCRACY FOR
AMERICA, AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. I'M EDITH
JACOBY FROM PALO ALTO, AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS JOE ELY. I LIVE IN
BRENTWOOD, CALIFORNIA, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS EILEEN SERGEANT. I'M
FROM HERE IN SACRAMENTO. ON
BEHALF OF MY CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN, I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ELAINE EL-BIZRI. I'M FROM PALO
ALTO AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS CATHERINE
ESPITIA FROM TRACY, CALIFORNIA,
AND I FERVENTLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. I'M CHRISTINE IKEN ALSO
FROM TRACY, AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL, MY NAME IS DAVID SCHMIDT.
I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN,
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING, JOHNNY PENA WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI,
RALPH FINLEY, I DROVE UP FROM
SAN JOSE THIS MORNING JUST TO
TELL YOU I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NANCY NEFF,
REPRESENTING THE DEAN,
DEMOCRATIC CLUB OF SILICON
VALLEY IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS KELLY CUTHBERTSON.
I'M FROM NAPA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
GARY APEL FROM MILL VALLEY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
VICKI MUELLER OLVERA I LIVE IN
SAN JOSE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK I'M JIM
DAVIDSON, I'M FROM LOS ALTOS AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. JOHN
FIORETTI, SAN JOSE SUPPORT CHRIS
LYNCH FROM SAN RAFAEL. PLEASE
SUPPORT. K¾T WEBER, SACRAMENTO,
LEGISLATOR FROM PEACE AND
FREEDOM PARTY. AND WE SUPPORT,
IF AMENDED. WE'RE AGAINST
PATCHING FUNDS. SO IF THAT'S IN
THERE, GRAHAM HEALY FROM WALNUT
CREEK IN SUPPORT, AMY HEALY FROM
WALNUT CREEK IN SUPPORT. SUSAN
PELIKAN FROM WOODLAND SPEAKING
IN BEHALF OF, INDIVISIBLE STATE
STRONG. AND ABOUT TEN OTHER
CHAPTERS, INCLUDING MY OWN YOLO
SUPPORT. SHIRLEY KALINOWSKI,
PLEASANT HILL STRONG SUPPORT.
SHIRLEY MCGRATH FROM WALNUT
CREEK, PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND LASTLY, I HAVE PROXIES FOR,
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS. COURAGE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND
ENDANGERED HABITATS LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WELL, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO EVERYONE. OH,
OKAY. GOOD. WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE,
JEFF TARTAGLIA AND ADVOCATE
SACRAMENTO. CARA DOGFIGHT SAC.
TRUE. THESE ARE VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS ALL IN SUPPORT OF
THIS. WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO CAME
TO SACRAMENTO TODAY TO VOICE
YOUR PERSONAL SUPPORT AND
SUPPORT FOR THE ORGANIZATIONS
YOU REPRESENT. IT DOES REALLY
MATTER TO US WHEN WE HEAR FROM
THE PUBLIC. SO I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO YOU FOR TAKING YOUR
TIME TO DO THAT. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO IS
OPPOSED, LEAD OPPOSITION COULD
COME FORWARD. OKAY. ANY
INDIVIDUAL OPPOSITION, SOMEONE
WISHING TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE? NO. OKAY. SEEING
NONE, THEN WE WILL TAKE IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. I DO NOT SEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE, WOULD YOU WOULD
YOU LIKE TO, WELL, I'LL JUST
PERSONALLY SAY THAT I SUPPORT
THIS BILL, AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT
YOU BROUGHT IT FORWARD. AND I
JUST WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. THAT'S CORRECT. YES.
OKAY. THAT'S GREAT. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YES, FIRST, I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE COME FAR AND WIDE
TO, FROM CALIFORNIA TO COME
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
GROUNDSWELL. I HOPE THAT THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE TAKING IT
SLOW AND SOCIALIZING AND
BUILDING THIS IDEA OUT WITH THE
PUBLIC, AS IT IS A GRASSROOTS
IDEA, SO THAT WE WON'T BE
RUSHING IT. YOU KNOW, ANYTIME
SOON. BUT IT WILL BE FROM 2026.
AND WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE, I HOPE TO RECEIVE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SO WE WILL PUT
THIS ON CALL UNTIL WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND THEN WE WILL VOTE ON
IT. THANK YOU AGAIN. OKAY. SO
NEXT WE HAVE I, I, I KNOW THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WAS HERE
EARLIER TOO. AND HE HAS THE NEXT
TWO BILLS. AND THEN WE WILL GO
AFTER THAT TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES. YES WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY, YOU MAY START. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES, FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 84 TO HELP
INCREASE LANGUAGE ACCESS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY. DO
YOU HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES?
HELLO. WELCOME. ALL RIGHT. SO
I'LL GO FIRST. YEAH. ALL RIGHT,
MY NAME IS BETH HERNANDEZ. HELLO
AGAIN. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE. WE'RE
HAPPY TO BE JOINING AS
CO-SPONSORS OF AB 884. I WANT TO
THANK YOU. FOR ADOPTING SO MANY
ELECTION REFORMS OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO VOTE.
UNFORTUNATELY, LANGUAGE ACCESS
HAS NOT BEEN BAKED INTO MANY OF
THOSE REFORMS. CURRENTLY, THE
FEDERAL VOTING RIGHTS ACT
PROVIDES THAT ALL ELECTION
MATERIALS MUST BE TRANSLATED IN
A LANGUAGE, IF A LANGUAGE GROUP
REACHES A SPECIFIED COUNTY
THRESHOLD. BUT THESE THRESHOLDS
ARE HIGH. ADDITIONALLY, THE
FEDERAL PROVISIONS ONLY APPLIES
TO SPANISH, ASIAN LANGUAGES, AND
NATIVE AMERICAN AND NATIVE
ALASKAN LANGUAGES. STATE LAW HAS
A MUCH LOWER THRESHOLD, BUT IN
TERMS OF WRITTEN MATERIALS ONLY
PROVIDES FOR TRANSLATED
REFERENCE BALLOTS, YOU CAN'T
ACTUALLY VOTE WITH ONE
OFFICIALLY, AND IN 2019, COURT
HAS LIMITED THE STATUTE, THE
STATE STATUTE, TO THE SAME
LANGUAGE CATEGORIES AS FEDERAL
LAW. WE'RE PART OF A LANGUAGE
ACCESS WORK GROUP WHICH
CONDUCTED SEVEN LISTENING
SESSIONS IN SIX LANGUAGES, AND
PARTICIPANTS EXPRESSED
FRUSTRATION WITH THE REFERENCE
BALLOTS, ESPECIALLY IN
COMPARISON TO IN LANGUAGE VOTING
BALLOTS. THIS BILL DOES TWO
THINGS. FIRST, FOR LARGER
GROUPS, IT CREATES A THRESHOLD
ONE LIKE THE ONE FOUND IN
FEDERAL LAW, BUT APPLIES IT TO
ANY LANGUAGE GROUP. IF, FOR
EXAMPLE, AN ARABIC SPEAKING
COMMUNITY OR ARMENIAN SPEAKING
COMMUNITY IN A COUNTY REACHES
THE LARGER THRESHOLD, VOTERS
WOULD BE ENTITLED TO ALL THE
TRANSLATED ALL OF THE VOTING
MATERIALS IN THEIR LANGUAGE. A
RECENT POLL CONDUCTED BY
BERKELEY INSTITUTE OF
GOVERNMENTAL STUDIES SHOWED THAT
THESE REFORMS ARE COVERED ARE
SUPPORTED BY THREE AND FOUR
VOTERS. SECOND, FOR SMALLER
LANGUAGE GROUPS, AB 884 KEEPS
THE EXISTING THRESHOLD FOUND IN
STATE LAW, BUT REQUIRES AN IN
LANGUAGE VOTABLE BALLOT INSTEAD
OF A REFERENCE BALLOT. IT ALSO
EXEMPTS EXPANDS. SORRY, IT ALSO
EXPANDS COVERAGE TO ANY LANGUAGE
GROUP THAT HITS THIS THRESHOLD,
REGARDING COST AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS, WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND OPPOSITIONS AS
WE THINK ABOUT THE STATE BUDGET
AND THINK ABOUT WHAT IS ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISHABLE, IN CONCLUSION,
FOR LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
VOTERS, A BARRIER TO VOTING IS
THE LACK OF TRANSLATED
MATERIALS. WE KNOW FROM AN
ACADEMIC STUDY THAT AND FROM
EVERYDAY STORIES THAT THE
TRANSLATED ELECTION MATERIALS
INCREASE VOTER REGISTRATION AND
TURNOUT AND AB 84 ELIMINATES OR
REDUCES THAT BARRIER, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A YES VOTE. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS RAMA
ABDI. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
ORGANIZING AND CAMPAIGNS WITH
THE PARTNERSHIP FOR ADVANCEMENT
OF NEW AMERICANS. PANA IS BASED
IN SAN DIEGO AND FOUNDED AND LED
BY REFUGEE AND IMMIGRANT. WE ARE
PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR OF AB 80
FOR A COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRACY
INCLUSIVE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
DIVERSE COMMUNITY. LANGUAGE
ACCESS IS A LARGE PART OF OUR
WORK FOR REFUGEE COMMUNITY. NOT
HAVING ACCESS TO LANGUAGE
SERVICES MAKES DIFFICULT FOR US
TO ENGAGE IN A SOCIETY. OUR
COMMUNITY ARE DIVERSE. WE ARE
MULTI-ETHNIC. NUMBERS ARE OFTEN
LOST IN THE CENSUS COUNT,
CURRENTLY, FEDERAL AND STATE
LANGUAGE ACCESS LAW DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE COMMUNITY WE WORK
WITH. MANY OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS SPEAK SOMALI, ARABIC,
AMHARIC BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL
LAW, DOES NOT INCLUDE AFRICAN
LANGUAGES. FOR THE LANGUAGE
ACCESS, WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
RECEIVE THE LANGUAGE ASSISTANCE
PROVIDED BY THE STATE. THERE ARE
A LOT OF CHANGES THAT CAME WHEN
SAN DIEGO ADOPTED THE VOTER
CHOICE ACT, AND BECAUSE OF
LANGUAGE, ARE NOT COVERED BY THE
STATE LAW. IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR
THE COMMUNITY TO RECEIVE THE
INFORMATION ON THOSE CHANGES,
INCLUDING REDUCTION OF VOTING
SITES. AS A PERSON WHO HAS
WORKED WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS
NAVIGATING ELECTION, I WANT TO
SHARE THAT REQUESTING
TRANSLATING MATERIAL OR HAVING
TO TRAVEL TO GET TRANSLATED
MATERIAL IS DIFFICULT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. MANY OF OUR ELDERS DO
NOT DRIVE AND WOULD PREFER TO
VOTE AT HOME WITH SAMPLE
MATERIAL IS DIFFICULT FOR THE
VOTERS TO COMPARE THE SAMPLE
BALLOT TO. ENGLISH BALLOT
PRIVACY IS ALSO AN ISSUE. OFTEN,
COMMUNITY ELDERS RELY ON OTHERS
WHEN TO HELP THEM VOTE WITH THE
WHEN THE WHEN TO HELP THEM WITH
THEIR BALLOT. SO FOR EXAMPLE,
ONE OF THE COMMUNITY MEMBER
EMPHASIZED THAT VOTING SHOULD BE
PRIVATE. IT SHOULD BE ME, MYSELF
AND I. OUR COMMUNITY WANT TO BE
PART OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE THE
SAMPLE BALLOT ARE THE START FOR
THAT. HAVING ACCESS TO ELECTION
INFORMATION ON VOTER BALLOT
WOULD MEAN THAT OUR COMMUNITY
WOULD NOT HAVE TO STRUGGLE BY
RELYING ON OTHERS, OR HAVE TO
COMPARE A SEPARATE DOCUMENT WHEN
THEY'RE VOTING. MANY, MANY NEW
RECENT ARRIVALS TO CALIFORNIA DO
NOT SPEAK THE LANGUAGE COVERED
BY STATE AND FEDERAL LAW, AND AB
88 WOULD FIX BY THIS. AB 8088
WOULD FIX THIS BY RECOGNIZING
OUR COMMUNITY AND PROVIDING
ACCESS TO INFORMATION AND BALLOT
THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND. AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I
REQUEST YOU TO VOTE. YES,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. WELL, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO OUR LEAD
WITNESSES, IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT? COME FORWARD,
PLEASE, AND SAY YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, FAITH LEE. WITH
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WERE IN SUPPORT, ALSO PROVIDING
A ME TOO FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. ABED
FRANKEL HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE IS THERE? ARE THERE
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO THIS
BILL? I'M NOT SEEING ANY. OH,
YOU ARE OKAY. YOU IF YOU'RE A
PRIMARY WITNESS, YOU MAY COME
FORWARD AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. OH, OKAY. GREAT. YOU
BOTH HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR MY NAME IS
TRICIA WEBER. I AM A CO-CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE, AND IT'S
VERY HARD TO SIT HERE AND OPPOSE
A BILL THAT DOES PROVIDE ACCESS
TO THE BALLOT. I APPRECIATE THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK WITH
BOTH THE SPONSORS AND THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE DURING THE
COURSE OF THIS BILL, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE STILL IN AN
OPPOSED POSITION DUE TO FISCAL
CONCERNS, THAT WITH THIS
COUNTY'S HAVING TO ABSORB QUITE
A BIT OF COSTS IN ORDER TO MAKE
THIS WORK, WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE
YET. I APPRECIATE THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO, TO WORK WITH US,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE STILL
OPPOSING DUE TO FISCAL CONCERNS.
OKAY. THANK YOU. YES. GO AHEAD.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING. ERIC, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL UNLESS AMENDED.
THE AIM OF THIS BILL IS
COMMENDABLE. WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
THE VOICES OF ALL CALIFORNIANS,
THOSE WITH DISABILITIES,
SENIORS, WORKING PARENTS, RECENT
IMMIGRANTS, EVERYONE, ARE VITAL
TO THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
DEMOCRACY. HOWEVER, AB 884
IMPOSED SIGNIFICANT COSTS ON
ELECTION ADMINISTRATION, WITH NO
APPROPRIATION TO OFFSET
IMMEDIATE OR ONGOING COSTS. THE.
THE BILL UNDERSCORES THE FLAWS
IN HOW THE STATE FINANCES
ELECTIONS, WHICH HAS LED TO
INCREASINGLY TECHNICAL AND
COMPLICATED ELECTIONS WITHOUT
UPFRONT FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT NEW
REQUIREMENTS. ELECTIONS ARE
CONDUCTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BY
COUNTIES ON BEHALF OF THE STATE,
AND MOST COUNTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR CONDUCTING
ELECTIONS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES, SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT RESIDE
WITHIN THEIR BOUNDARIES. WHILE
CITIES AND DISTRICTS TYPICALLY
PAY COUNTIES FOR ADMINISTERING
THEIR ELECTIONS, THE STATE
TYPICALLY DOES NOT. COUNTIES
TYPICALLY HAVE ONE METHOD TO
SEEK STATE FUNDING FOR ELECTION
COSTS. NAVIGATING THE COSTLY AND
COMPLICATED STATE MANDATE
PROCESS, WHICH CAN TAKE YEARS
BEFORE ANY FUNDING IS RECEIVED
FROM THE STATE. DURING THOSE
YEARS, THE LEGISLATURE CAN
SUSPEND A MANDATE AT ANY TIME,
LEAVING LOCAL OFFICIALS TORN
BETWEEN ABSORBING ALL COSTS.
WITH NO STATE SUPPORT OR CEASING
TO PROVIDE A SERVICE EXPECTED BY
OTHER CONSTITUENTS. OVER THE
YEARS, THE STATE HAS SUSPENDED
SEVERAL ELECTION RELATED
MANDATES, INCLUDING PROVIDING
ABSENTEE BALLOTS TO ANY
REGISTERED VOTER, VERIFYING
SIGNATURES ON PROVISIONAL BALLOT
ENVELOPES, AND TABULATING
ABSENTEE BALLOTS BY PRECINCT.
AMONG OTHERS. CURRENTLY, THE
STATE HAS ACCUMULATED A BACKLOG
OF $72.5 MILLION IN UNPAID
REIMBURSEMENT CLAIMS OWED TO
COUNTIES FOR SUSPENDED ELECTION
RELATED MANDATES. TO QUOTE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE,
THE PROCESS THE STATE USES TO
ACHIEVE ITS LOCAL ELECTION
PRIORITIES SIMPLY HAS NOT
WORKED. FOR THESE REASONS, WE
ARE REGRETFULLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL WITHOUT AN APPROPRIATION TO
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU. OKAY.
THANK YOU. BEFORE WE MOVE ON, WE
WOULD LIKE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SO I'M GOING TO ASK THE
ASSISTANT TO CALL THE ROLL BLAKE
SPEARS, PRESENT BLAKE SPEAR,
PRESENT ONE HERE, ONE HERE.
ALLEN. HERE ALLEN HERE. MENGIBAR
HERE. MENGIBAR HERE. NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO. UMBERG OKAY. THANK
YOU. IF WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM WHO IS OPPOSED, PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND STATE YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION. MADAM CHAIR,
DYLAN ELLIOTT ON BEHALF OF THE
SOLANO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
ROOM? IN OPPOSITION. OKAY, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS? I'M NOT
SEEING ANY. I'M. I'M SORRY TO
HEAR ABOUT THE BUDGET PROBLEMS
WHICH YOU DESCRIBED. THAT IS ON
AN UNFORTUNATE SITUATION. I AM
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK THAT IT HAS A HIGH VALUE,
AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THE FUNDING PROBLEMS
THAT YOU'RE DISCUSSING. THANK
YOU FOR RAISING THEM IN YOUR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY TODAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SIMILARLY, LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE WITH THOSE WHO
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION IN
HELPING TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CONCERN ABOUT THE FISCAL IMPACT
OF STATE MANDATES. AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN ADDRESS THAT ISSUE SHOULD
THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR VOTE.
OKAY, GREAT, THE MEASURE Ó.
SENATOR ALLEN. YEAH, I JUST I DO
WANT TO, YOU KNOW, I THINK THESE
FISCAL ISSUES ARE VERY REAL, AND
I GUESS IT'LL GET ADDRESSED IN
APPROPRIATIONS. BUT I DO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO END OF THE DAY,
ALL OF THESE GOALS ARE VERY
LAUDABLE, ESPECIALLY THE ONES IN
THIS BILL. AND YET WE KNOW IT'S
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT. AND ONE
THING WE HEAR ABOUT ALL THE TIME
IN THIS COMMITTEE IS THE
FINANCIAL PRESSURES THAT ARE
THAT THE COUNTIES ARE FACING AS
THEY TRY TO IMPOSE. SO THEY TRY
TO IMPLEMENT ALL THE MANDATES
AND REQUESTS THAT WE HAVE FOR
THEM. SO FIGURING OUT A WAY TO
MAKE IT WORK AND WORKING THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS, ETC. IS
GOING TO BE REALLY VITAL. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDT OR
SENATOR NGUYEN. SORRY THEY THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, JUST A QUICK
QUESTION YOU HAVE HERE REQUIRES
THAT AT LEAST 10,000 LIMITED
ENGLISH. IS THAT 10,000
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THE
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA. THAT REQUEST
IS FOR THE, ANOTHER LANGUAGE, OR
IS IT 10,000 PEOPLE IN
POPULATION? YES, IF I MAY, MADAM
CHAIR THE LEAD. WITNESS ALSO TO
MÀ. YEAH. SO, IT'S 10,000 WITHIN
A COUNTY, OF. AND IT WOULD BE
FROM THE CENSUS COUNT. THE
SECRETARY OF STATE USUALLY DOES
A SPECIAL REQUEST, A SPECIAL
TABULATION. SO IT WOULD BE
COUNTING 10,000 AND THE
QUALIFYING, IT'S 10,000 OF
ADULTS WHO ARE LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT. SO IT'S A IT'S A
SUBCATEGORY OF THE TOTAL
POPULATION. SO BY POPULATION NOT
BY REGISTERED VOTERS REQUEST.
THAT'S RIGHT. AND THAT'S DONE
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, MAKING THESE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE, SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO REQUIRE EXTRA STEPS FOR
SOME PEOPLE. RIGHT THAT'S THE
IDEA IS TO MAKE LANGUAGE ACCESS
ACTUALLY ACCESSIBLE. AND I'M ALL
FOR THAT. I'M 1,000% WITH YOU ON
THAT. I'M JUST TRYING TO LOOK AT
THE COUNTY'S PERSPECTIVE IF
LIKE, SAY, I'VE GOT MOSTLY
ORANGE COUNTY AND THREE CITIES
IN LOS ANGELES, RIGHT? SO ORANGE
COUNTY, THERE'S WE'RE VERY
DIVERSE. BUT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE 10,000 INDIVIDUALS WHO
REQUEST FOR THESE BALLOT
MATERIALS IN A SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE, BECAUSE WE'VE GOT A
LOT OF, YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT 3.2
MILLION PEOPLE. SO IF I'M JUST
GOING TO MAKE IT UP, I DON'T
KNOW, LET'S SAY TO GAELIC
FILIPINO, AND I DON'T KNOW, THE
I DON'T KNOW THE NUMBER. I'M
JUST MAKING THIS UP. OKAY. LET'S
SAY THERE'S 50,000 FILIPINOS WHO
LIVE IN ORANGE COUNTY, BUT ONLY
SAY, 3000 WHO ACTUALLY REQUEST
FOR TAGALOG MATERIALS. SO IS
THAT SAYING? THEN THE COUNTIES
SHOULD GO AHEAD AND TRANSLATE
IT, EVEN THOUGH THERE'S ONLY
2000 WHO ASKED FOR IT, SO THAT
THAT'S WHERE MY CONCERN IS,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S A LOT OF
I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS. THERE'S NO DOUBT. MY
CONCERN IS, ARE WE TRANSLATING
MATERIALS AND PUTTING KEEPING
THEM ON THE SIDE JUST FOR WHAT?
I MEAN, WHAT IF THERE'S NOBODY
WHO REQUESTS? YEAH SO AND IN
ORANGE COUNTY, THE FEDERAL, THE
LANGUAGES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
COVERED UNDER FEDERAL LAW ARE
CHINESE, KOREAN, SPANISH AND
VIETNAMESE UNDER AB 84. IT WOULD
ALSO INCLUDE, TAGALOG AND FARSI,
WHICH ARE PRETTY LARGE,
SIGNIFICANT COMMUNITIES WITHIN
ORANGE COUNTY AND, AND IT WOULD
BE LOOKING AT POPULATION FROM
THE CENSUS. THAT IS CORRECT.
OKAY OKAY. THANK THANK YOU, CAN
I MAKE A COMMENT? ASSEMBLYMAN,
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL. I
THINK HEARING THE CONCERN OF THE
COUNTY MAY BE SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT IS AS YOU MOVE FORWARD OR
IN THE FUTURE IS SOMETHING TO
LOOK AT, THE NUMBER OF REQUESTS
BY THE VOTERS. BECAUSE THIS IS
THIS IS SPECIFICALLY VOTING
MATERIALS. SO IT'S NOT FOR
POPULATION. SO I THINK THAT
MIGHT MAYBE HELP THE COUNTIES A
LITTLE BIT IF THEY DON'T HAVE
TO, YOU KNOW, LOOK AT EVERY
LANGUAGE OR, YOU KNOW, I MEAN
THERE'S ENOUGH PEOPLE IN ORANGE
COUNTY THAT NEEDS FARSI AND
THERE'S ENOUGH THAT TO GARLIC. I
KNOW THAT, BUT I THINK JUST GO
GO FORWARD. MAYBE THAT MIGHT
HELP IN EASING THE COUNTY'S IN
TERMS OF THE BUDGETARY A LITTLE
BIT, BUT I'M I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
THE BILL TODAY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR, AND I KNOW THAT
YOU ALSO ACKNOWLEDGED THE
IMPORTANCE COMING FROM A
BACKGROUND WITH THE COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY TO, THAT IS
CERTAINLY THE INTENT. AND
HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT SHOULD THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
ABLE TO CLOSE AGAIN SINCE WE HAD
QUESTIONS AFTER YOU'RE CLOSE.
THANK YOU. I'LL LEAVE THAT AS MY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. OKAY. THANK YOU,
WELL, LET'S GO AHEAD AND VOTE.
Þ. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS?
DO ANY MEMBERS WISH TO MOVE?
I'LL MOVE IT. OKAY. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
NGUYEN, WHICH IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
BREAKSPEAR I WHEN I WHEN I ALLEN
ALLEN I MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN. PORTANTINO UMBERG. ALL
RIGHT. IT IS FOUR ZERO AND IT'S
ON CALL. THANK YOU AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW. YOU HAVE A SECOND
BILL AB 996. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES, THIS BILL HAS OF
COURSE, A UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE
AND A PERSONAL DYNAMIC IN WHICH
THERE WAS A RECENT ELECTION THAT
WAS VERY CLOSE. AND AS I
REPRESENT AND RESIDE FROM THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA,
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE
PROVISIONS ON AUTOMATIC
RECOUNTS, WE HELP TO AMPLIFY
THAT SIMILAR TYPE OF POLICY AT A
STATEWIDE LEVEL TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY VOTE DOES INDEED COUNT FOR
PRIMARY ELECTIONS. THIS BILL
WOULD THEN REQUIRE THAT THE
DIFFERENCE OF A AN ELECTION, IF
THERE ARE LESS THAN, 0.25 VOTES
CAST OF DIFFERENCE, THAT THERE
WOULD BE AN AUTOMATIC RECOUNT
COMMENSURATE WITH THAT OF THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA. AND WITH
ME TODAY ALSO IS REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY. THANK
YOU. YOU MAY GO AHEAD. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS MARY HANAUER. I'M LEAD
DEPUTY COUNTY COUNSEL FOR THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA. FOR THE
PAST SIX YEARS, I'VE SERVED AS
PRIMARY ADVISE COUNSEL FOR THE
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS, PROVIDING
REAL TIME ADVICE THROUGHOUT EACH
ELECTION AND RECOUNT DURING THE
RECENT CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT 16
RECOUNT, I COLLABORATED WITH
COLLEAGUES IN SAN MATEO COUNTY
AND THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO
PROVIDE DAILY ADVICE AND COUNSEL
TO THE REGISTRAR THROUGH THAT
UNPRECEDENTED RECOUNT. WHILE THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA DOES NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL, I
AM HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT?
NOT SEEING ANYONE, ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION, YOU MAY COME FORWARD
AS THE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
NOT SEEING ANY. DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION? OKAY. I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST ASK IF YOU
ARE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS.
YES, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR. OKAY, GREAT. THANK YOU.
THEN WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? YES ASSEMBLYMAN. THIS
IS LONG OVERDUE. HAVING WON AN
ELECTION BY FIVE VOTES, I HAD TO
ASK FOR. I'M SORRY. BY THREE
VOTES, I HAD TO ASK FOR A
RECOUNT MYSELF. AND I WAS ON THE
HOOK FOR THE PAYMENT OF TENS AND
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. HAD WE NOT
BECOME VICTORIOUS OF THAT
RECOUNT. AND SO, YOU KNOW, IT
WASN'T A STATE RACE OR A
CONGRESSIONAL RACE, IT WAS A
COUNTY RACE. AND SO THIS IS LONG
OVERDUE. HOPEFULLY IN THE
FUTURE, THEY CAN ALSO ADD IN THE
COUNTY AS WELL FOR COUNTY RACES
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S NECESSARY
AND IT MAKES IT IT HELPS THE
CANDIDATE AS THEY MOVE FORWARD,
KNOWING THAT IT'S ONLY, YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE LESS THAN 25 VOTES.
LIKE I SAID, I WAS ONLY THREE.
AND SO I'M SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU. OKAY. THANKS
VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? IT DOES SEEM LIKE A
BILL THAT'S OVERDUE AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT,
LET'S SEE, DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALLOWING ME
TO CLOSE AND ACKNOWLEDGE. NUMBER
ONE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA FOR
ALREADY ADOPTING SUCH A POLICY
TO HELP ENSURE THAT EVERY VOTE
DOES COUNT AND THAT THERE'S A
CONTINUOUS INTEGRITY IN THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS. NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO IS TO SENATOR
NGUYEN'S POINT, AS REFLECTED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ON THE
MOST RECENT CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT 16. THERE WAS A TIE OF
THIS, CONGRESSIONAL RACE IN THIS
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY. IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE, THERE WAS A
RECOUNT REQUESTED IN MY NAME
AGAINST MY WISHES, AND THIS WAS
PAID FOR BY DARK MONEY OF A
SUPER PAC. SO WHEN ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS, DISTURB
THE PROCESS, WE WANT TO HELP
ENSURE THAT THERE'S AN AUTOMATIC
PROCESS. SO YOU'RE GETTING THAT
TYPE OF INFLUENCE OUT OF THAT
ENDEAVOR. SO THIS AGAIN HELPS TO
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS MIRRORING THAT
OF THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA AND
HOPEFULLY DOING SO GIVEN THE
ALSO PERSONAL EXPERIENCES THAT
OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
HAVE ALSO FACED IN THEIR TENURE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION? OKAY, GREAT.
THANK YOU. LET'S GO AHEAD AND
VOTE. MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR BLAKESTER, I SHAKESPEARE
I WHEN I WHEN I ALLEN I ALLEN I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NEWMAN
PORTANTINO UMBERG FOR SO IT'S
FOUR ZERO AND IT'S ON CALL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. AND WE DO
WE HAVE HAD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES WAITING PATIENTLY. SO IF
IT'S OKAY WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PILAR AND SHE COULD GO NEXT. IS
THAT ALL RIGHT WITH YOU? ARE YOU
ARE YOU TRYING TO GET TO YOUR
COMMITTEE? YOU HAVE TWO OTHER
COMMITTEES. OKAY, WELL, WE'LL GO
IN THE ORDER THAT IT'S LISTED.
GO AHEAD. YOU CAN GO NEXT. I
APOLOGIZE. OKAY. OKAY, I
OVERDRANK NOW. OKAY THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, SINCE 1913,
CALIFORNIA LAW HAS PROHIBITED A
PERSON FROM RUNNING FOR MORE
THAN ONE OFFICE AT A PRIMARY
ELECTION. THAT'S NOT JUST THE
OPINION OF WHAT THE LAW SAYS.
IT'S ALSO HOW THE LAW HAS BEEN
INTERPRETED FOR DECADES BY THE
CALIFORNIA SECRETARIES OF STATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL FROM BOTH
MAJOR PARTIES. NONPARTISAN
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS AND
MULTIPLE STATE AND FEDERAL
COURTS. AND THE LOGIC BEHIND THE
LAW IS OBVIOUS. WITHOUT IT, A
CANDIDATE COULD FILE TO RUN FOR
EVERY CONGRESSIONAL SEAT IN THE
STATE AT THE SAME TIME, OR FOR
EVERY STATEWIDE ELECTIVE OFFICE
AT A SINGLE PRIMARY ELECTION.
NOTWITHSTANDING THAT FACT, IN
DECEMBER, A SACRAMENTO SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGE ORDERED THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO PLACE A
CANDIDATE'S NAME ON THE BALLOT
FOR A CONGRESSIONAL SEAT, EVEN
THOUGH THAT SAME CANDIDATE'S
NAME WAS ALREADY ON THE BALLOT
FOR AN ASSEMBLY SEAT. EVEN AS
THE COURT REACHED ITS DECISION,
THE JUDGE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT IT
DEFIES COMMON SENSE TO FIND THE
LAW PERMITS A CANDIDATE TO RUN
FOR TWO OFFICES DURING THE SAME
ELECTION. AB 1784 CLARIFIES THAT
STATE LAW PROHIBITS A PERSON
FROM FILING NOMINATION
DOCUMENTS. MORE THAN FOR MORE
THAN ONE OFFICE AT A PRIMARY
ELECTION. THE CLARIFICATION
ENSURES THAT THE LAW IS APPLIED
IN THE WAY THAT IT HAS BEEN
INTERPRETED FOR DECADES.
ADDITIONALLY, AB 1787 I'M SORRY,
1784 ALLOWS A CANDIDATE TO
WITHDRAW NOMINATION DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY FILED AT A
PRIMARY ELECTION, AS LONG AS
THOSE DOCUMENTS WERE NOT FOR
STATEWIDE OFFICE. THIS
WITHDRAWAL PROCEDURE IS
CAREFULLY DESIGNED TO GIVE
CANDIDATES FLEXIBILITY TO ADJUST
THEIR PLANS IF CIRCUMSTANCES
CHANGE. WHILE A VOIDING CHANGES
TO ELECTIONS. TIMELINES THAT
THREATEN ELECTIONS OFFICIALS,
PREPARATIONS FOR CONDUCTING THE
ELECTION. I WORK CLOSELY WITH
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS IN
DEVELOPING THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL, AND I'M HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT AB 1784 HAS THE
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS, THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
AND SECRETARY OF STATE, DOCTOR
SHIRLEY WEBER, AMONG OTHERS. AB
1784 WILL NOT CHANGE AND IS NOT
INTENDED TO CHANGE WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE CANDIDATE FILING
PROCESS FOR THIS YEAR'S PRIMARY
ELECTION. INSTEAD, IT MERELY
SEEKS TO CLARIFY THE RULES FOR
FUTURE ELECTIONS TO AVOID
UNNECESSARY UNCERTAINTY AND
VOTER CONFUSION. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 1784 IS
TRICIA WEBER, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. AND I
HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS, Tð TIM
MØT, ON BEHALF OF THE SECRETARY
OF STATE, JULIAN WEBER.
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. OKAY GREAT. WELL, YOU BOTH
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
CHAIR BLAKESPEAR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS TRICIA
WEBER. I AM THE CO-CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE, AND WE
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN'S BILL 1784,
WHICH CLARIFIES, THE NOMINATION
PROCESS DURING A PRIMARY
ELECTION AND, PUTS INTO PLACE
WHAT WE WERE ALREADY DOING, UP
UNTIL THIS PAST YEAR. AND IT IT
GIVES A PROCESS FOR PEOPLE TO
WITHDRAW THEIR NOMINATION DURING
A PRIMARY IF NEED BE. AND HELPS
TO MAKE THE BALLOT LOOK A LITTLE
CLEANER AND MORE UNDERSTANDING
FOR VOTERS. AND I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THAT THERE MAY BE. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. TIM
GRIMALDI, ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY
OF STATE SHIRLEY WEBER, THE
SECRETARY IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE. IT WILL PROVIDE,
AS HAS BEEN SAID, ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY AND GUIDANCE IN THE
AREA OF CANDIDATE FILINGS. WE
BELIEVE IT WILL ALSO FURTHER THE
STATE'S COMPELLING INTEREST IN
PREVENTING VOTER CONFUSION AND
HELPING HELPING TO LIMIT COSTLY
SPECIAL ELECTIONS, AMONG OTHER
THINGS. THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
WOULD ADD TO THE CODE A SORELY
NEEDED DEFINITION FOR STATEWIDE
OFFICE, PROVIDING GREATER
CLARITY MOVING FORWARD. WITH
THAT, WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE, ANYBODY WISHING TO
BE AN OPPOSITION WITNESS AND
COME FORWARD, SEEING NONE. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? SEEING
NONE. WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? OKAY, I JUST WILL
SHARE THAT. I REALLY APPLAUD
YOU, THE AUTHOR, FOR SUCH A
SIMPLE AND COMMON SENSE
NON-BUREAUCRATIC SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM THAT NO ONE EVEN
REALLY KNEW EXISTED UNTIL THE
SACRAMENTO SUPERIOR COURT HANDED
DOWN ITS RULING LAST YEAR.
PEOPLE SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO RUN
FOR TWO OFFICES AT THE SAME
TIME, AND CREATING A PROCESS TO
LET CANDIDATES WITHDRAW THEIR
NOMINATION PAPERS MAKE SENSE. SO
I SUPPORT THIS BILL, AND I'M
GRATEFUL THAT YOU BROUGHT IT
FORWARD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. OKAY, SO DOES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELOISE GOMEZ
REYES. WE HAVE A MOTION BY,
SENATOR MENGIBAR, AND THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BLAKE SPEAR, I BLAKE
SPEAR I WHEN I WHEN I ALLEN I
ALLEN I MENGIBAR AND GUEVARA I
NEWMAN PORTANTINO UMBERG. IT'S
FOUR ZERO AND WE WILL LEAVE IT
ON CALL. THANK YOU. SO MUCH.
OKAY. LONG SUFFERING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES, IT'S YOUR TURN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WE
APPRECIATE IT. THIS IS AB 2724.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
2724. THIS BILL WILL ALLOW HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO PREREGISTER
TO VOTE BY THE END OF THE 11TH
GRADE, VOTER PRE-REGISTRATION IS
ALREADY THE LAW. WE CAN
PRE-REGISTER OUR 16 AND 17 YEAR
OLDS. IT'S AN EXCELLENT TOOL TO
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THE 16 AND
17 YEAR OLDS TO PRE-REGISTER TO
VOTE SO THAT UPON THEIR 18TH
BIRTHDAY, THEY ARE AUTOMATICALLY
REGISTERED VOTERS EVERY ELECTION
CYCLE, WE DISCUSS THE LOW VOTER
TURNOUT FROM ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS PASS UP ON THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXERCISE THEIR
DEMOCRATIC RIGHT TO VOTE AT
EVERY ELECTION. ONE CRITICAL
STRATEGY WE CAN EMPLOY TO
ADDRESS THIS IS BY ENSURING THAT
YOUNG CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE ARE REGISTERED
TO DO SO. CURRENTLY, ONLY 11% OF
OUR 16 AND 17 YEAR OLDS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ACTUALLY
PRE-REGISTERED TO VOTE. BY
FOCUSING ON OUR YOUTH AND
BRINGING THE RESOURCES TO THEM
AT THEIR HIGH SCHOOLS, WE CAN
ENSURE MORE CALIFORNIANS,
ESPECIALLY YOUNG CALIFORNIANS,
ARE VOTING AND DEVELOPING THE
HABIT OF DOING SO AT AN EARLIER
AGE. CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IS
INVALUABLE, AND THAT'S WHY WE
NEED AB 2724. THE HIGH SCHOOL
VOTER REGISTRATION ACT, SO MORE
VOICES CAN BE HEARD AT THE POLLS
ON ELECTION DAY HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT ARE OZZY DOLAN, A
STUDENT ORGANIZER WITH INLAND
CONGREGATIONS UNITED FOR CHANGE,
AND MARIA TELLEZ, A FIELD FELLOW
WITH POWER. CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU, CHAIR, VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS OZZY DOLAN. I'M A JUNIOR
AT PACIFIC HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN
BERNARDINO AND A STUDENT VOTER
ENGAGEMENT LEAD AS A PART OF
ENGLAND CONGREGATIONS UNITED FOR
CHANGE. I CðC AS ICUC. WE ARE A
MEMBER ORGANIZATION OF PICO,
CALIFORNIA. I AM HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB 2724, IN
HOPES TO SHARE WHY THE THIS BILL
IS SO IMPORTANT FOR STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF. THROUGH MY
PARTICIPATION WITH ICUC, I HAVE
LEARNED ABOUT MANY DIFFERENT
ISSUES THAT MAY IMPACT MY
COMMUNITY, AND IT HAS GIVEN ME
THE CHANCE TO CONTRIBUTE TO
POSITIVE CHANGE. ONE THING I'VE
LEARNED THROUGH ICUC, AND THE
ONE I'M MOST PASSIONATE ABOUT,
IS SPREADING RAISING YOUTH'S
ENGAGEMENT IN VOTING AND
SPREADING VOTER LITERACY THROUGH
MY WORK AS A STUDENT VOTER
ENGAGEMENT LEAD, I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO WITNESS HOW MUCH MY
PEERS AND I CARE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE. OUR COUNTRY AND
COMMUNITIES ARE CURRENTLY
FACING. I HAVE ALSO WITNESSED
HOW, UNFORTUNATELY, THAT PASSION
CAN TURN INTO FRUSTRATION DUE TO
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT HOW TO
TRANSLATE OUR BELIEFS INTO
MEANINGFUL ACTIONS. MY
UNDERSTANDING OF VOTING IN
PREREGISTRATION HAS BEEN THANKS
TO MY INVOLVEMENT WITH ICUC AND
THE GUIDANCE OF ONE DEDICATED
TEACHER AT MY SCHOOL. I AM
CONCERNED THAT STUDENTS WITHOUT
ACCESS TO THESE RESOURCES MIGHT
MISS OUT ON THE CHANCE TO LEARN
ABOUT THIS CRUCIAL INFORMATION,
LIKE, I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO. AB
2724 PRESENTS A CRUCIAL
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS GAP
BY PROVIDING COMPREHENSIVE VOTER
EDUCATION IN OUR SCHOOLS. I
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
HOLDS IMMENSE POTENTIAL TO
EMPOWER YOUTH LIKE MYSELF TO
BECOME INFORMED AND ENGAGED
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR DEMOCRACY,
AND WILL HELP ESTABLISH THE
FOUNDATION FOR FOSTERING A
STRONG CULTURE OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AMONG OUR YOUTH.
THIS, WITHOUT A DOUBT, WILL SEND
A STRONG MESSAGE THAT OUR VOICES
MATTER AND THAT YOUTH VOTER
ENGAGEMENT IS CRUCIAL FOR
SHAPING THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE
AND COUNTRY. PLEASE HELP US PASS
AB 2724. IN ORDER TO INFORM OUR
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS THE ONES
THAT WILL EVENTUALLY LEAD TO THE
FUTURE AND HELP US PROVIDE THEM
TOOLS, THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO BE
ABLE TO CREATE A SUCCESSFUL AND
PROSPEROUS FUTURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR COMING HERE FROM SAN
BERNARDINO TO TESTIFY. WE
APPRECIATE IT. GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
MARIA TELLEZ. I LIVE IN
PITTSBURG, CALIFORNIA. I AM A
FIELD ORGANIZER WITH POWER
CALIFORNIA ACTION. FOR THE PAST
TWO MONTHS, I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON A VOTER
REGISTRATION PROGRAM. I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF GOING TO PITTSBURG
HIGH SCHOOL AS AN ALUM TO
FACILITATE PRESENTATIONS ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF VOTING AND GETTING
STUDENTS REGISTERED, AND
PREREGISTER TO VOTE. MY TEAM AND
I WERE ABLE TO REGISTER AND
PRE-REGISTER 400 STUDENTS. I WAS
BLOWN AWAY BY THE ATTENTION AND
SERIOUSNESS IN WHICH THESE
STUDENTS TOOK THE PRESENTATIONS
AND DECIDED THAT THEY WOULD
REGISTER AND PRE-REGISTER TO
VOTE. THEY SHOWED THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE READY TO LISTEN AND
READY TO EXERCISE THEIR VOICE.
ALL THEY NEED IS THE INFORMATION
TO BE AVAILABLE TO COMMIT.
HOWEVER, THERE WAS A HIGH SCHOOL
IN THE DISTRICT THAT DID NOT
ALLOW ME TO DO THIS WITH AB
2724. IT ENSURES THAT ALL HIGH
SCHOOLERS GET THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN OUR GOVERNMENT,
AND THAT VOTER REGISTRATION
HAPPENS IN IN ALL HIGH SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA. FURTHERMORE, IN
HIGH SCHOOL, YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY LEARNING ABOUT CIVICS
AND GOVERNMENT, WHICH MAKES IT A
PERFECT OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEM TO EXERCISE REAL WORLD
CIVIC PARTICIPATION. EVIDENCE
SHOWS THAT WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE
VOTE IN THEIR FIRST FEW
CONSECUTIVE ELECTIONS, THEY
BECOME LIFETIME VOTERS. FROM THE
LAST ELECTION CYCLES, WE'VE SEEN
MORE AND MORE YOUNG PEOPLE TURN
OUT TO THE POLLS TO VOTE ON THE
ISSUE THAT MATTERS MOST TO THEM
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES. BEING A
DACA RECIPIENT, I CANNOT VOTE
MYSELF. SO ALL I SO I DO ALL I
CAN TO ENCOURAGE OTHERS TO VOTE,
ESPECIALLY YOUNG PEOPLE. I
ENCOURAGE YOU AND URGE YOU TO DO
THE SAME AND SUPPORT AB 2724 AND
GIVE YOUNG FOLKS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SURPRISE YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT? OKAY GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS ANGELA. I'M
A YOUTH ORGANIZER WITH ILLINOIS
CONGREGATION UNITED FOR CHANGE,
AND I'M HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB 2724. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. ARE THERE ANY IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO COME FORWARD, SEEING
NONE, ANYBODY WISHING TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I
DON'T SEE ANY. SO WE WILL ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE. THANK YOU. AND I
WANT TO THANK OZZY AND MARIA FOR
COMING TO TESTIFY. THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. TRYING TO GET
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE TO GET
PREREGISTERED SO THAT ON THEIR
18TH BIRTHDAY, THEY ARE
REGISTERED VOTERS AND GET THEM
EXCITED ABOUT VOTING AND BEING
INVOLVED. INVOLVED CIVICALLY.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MADAM CHAIR,
I JUST WANTED TO SAY ONE THING.
YES. GO AHEAD. I MEAN, IN THE
MARCH PRIMARY, MY AGE GROUP OF
18 TO 35, I THINK IT WAS LIKE 2
TO 4% IN LA COUNTY VOTED THAT.
SO I COMMEND YOU AGAIN FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES, WE KNOW THAT DEMOCRACY
WORKS WHEN PEOPLE ARE ENGAGED IN
THE PROCESS. AND BEING
REGISTERED TO VOTE. IS THAT
FIRST STEP. SO THANK YOU AGAIN
TO BOTH WITNESSES FOR COMING TO
TESTIFY, AND WITH THAT, LET'S
SEE, DO WE HAVE A MOTION,
SENATOR MENJIVAR, WAS THAT A
MOTION? YES. ON AB 2724. AND THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS BLAKE
SPEAR. AYE. WICKS FOR AYE. WHEN
NO ONE. NO. ALAN MENGIBAR. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. NEWMAN. PORTANTINO
UMBERG. IT'S TWO ONE, AND WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL. THANK YOU
, THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT, I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER AUTHORS. SO
I THINK WE WILL GO TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE ONE
ITEM ON CONSENT. IT'S AB 2631.
AND SENATOR NGUYEN HAS MOVED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK YOU.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS WICKS FOR AYE.
BLAKESPEAR I WHEN I WHEN I ALAN
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. I NEWMAN
PORTANTINO UMBERG 3030. AND WE
WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL. OKAY.
AND WE WILL GO BACK TO AB 270
FROM LEE AS AMENDED. WE DID NOT
HAVE A QUORUM, SO WE DID NOT
VOTE AT THAT TIME. BUT WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND DO THAT NOW. WAS THERE
A MOTION ON THAT BILL? OKAY,
SENATOR MENGIBAR MOVED. THANK
YOU. ITEM ONE AB 270. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS.
LARKSPUR, A LARKSPUR I11 NÓ ALAN
MENGIBAR. I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO UMBERG TWO. IT'S TWO
ONE AND WE WILL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL. AND I DO SEE AN AUTHOR HAS
COME. THANK YOU SO MUCH. IT'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN WITH AB
3184. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN,
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR MEASURE.
HOW ARE YOU? THANK YOU. CHAIR
BLAKE SPEER AND SENATORS, UNDER
EXISTING LAW, THE SECRETARY OF
STATE COMPILES DATA AND ISSUES A
REPORT ON VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
REJECTIONS CATEGORIZED BY THE
REJECTION REASON. CURRENTLY, THE
SECRETARY IS CHARGED WITH
REPORTING ON ALL ELECTIONS,
INCLUDING LOCALLY RUN ELECTIONS,
AND IS DOING HER BEST TO REPORT.
HOWEVER, THE SECRETARY OF STATE
DOES NOT HAVE A DIRECT ROLE IN
LOCAL ELECTIONS AND IS NOT THE
KEEPER OF LOCAL DATA. SO THERE'S
THERE CAN'T BE A GUARANTEE THAT
THE REPORT IS 100% COMPLETE AND
ACCURATE. IT'D BE 3184 WOULD
CLARIFY THAT THE REPORT ON VOTE
BY MAIL BALLOT REJECTION DATA
ISSUED BY THE SECRETARY OF STATE
APPLIES TO ELECTIONS THAT ARE
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS APPROACH
IS FAIRLY TYPICAL, WHERE STATE
AND FEDERAL ELECTION DATA IS
HANDLED BY THE SECRETARY AND
LOCAL DATA IS HANDLED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THEREFORE, AB 3184
WOULD PROVIDE THAT THE VOTE BY
MAIL REJECTED BALLOT REPORT
POSTED BY THE SECRETARY OF STATE
APPLY TO EVERY ELECTION FOR
STATE OFFICE, AS WELL AS
EXPLICITLY INCLUDE STATE RECALL
ELECTIONS AND STATE AND FEDERAL
SPECIAL VACANCY ELECTIONS, BUT
NOT PURELY LOCAL ELECTIONS.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE.
AND I'M JOINED TODAY BY TIM
CROMARTIE ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY
OF STATE WEBER, WHO'S THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS, TIM
CARMODY, ON BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, FIRST,
TRADITIONALLY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE HAD NO RESPONSIBILITY FOR
REPORTING ON LOCAL ELECTIONS
PRIOR TO SB 503, WHICH CREATED
THE CURRENT REQUIREMENT JUST
FOUR YEARS AGO. OUR OFFICE HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN CHARGED WITH
PUBLISHING DATA ON STATE AND
FEDERAL ELECTIONS ONLY. SECOND,
ALTHOUGH CURRENT LAW EXPRESSLY
REQUIRES LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
REPORT TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE
WITHIN 31 DAYS OF AN ELECTION,
THE NUMBER OF REJECTED BALLOTS,
FULLY 50% OF THEM, DO NOT COMPLY
WITHOUT CONTACT BEING INITIATED
BY OUR OFFICE. THAT CONTACT
OFTEN CONSISTS OF NOT ONE, BUT A
SERIES OF CALLS AND EMAILS TO
ELICIT THE DESIRED INFORMATION,
WHICH WE SUBSEQUENTLY PUBLISH.
NOW, FOR THAT 50% SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES ARE BEING DEVOTED TO
CONTACTING LOCALS, CONFIRMING
WHETHER THEIR ELECTION WAS IN
FACT HELD, BECAUSE IN SOME CASES
IT HAS NOT BEEN FOR VARIOUS
REASONS. HOW MANY REJECTED
BALLOTS RESULTED AND WHAT THE
REASONS WERE FOR THE REJECTION
IN EACH CASE. AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE, THIS IS A TIME
CONSUMING, STAFF INTENSIVE
PROCESS. NOW, IT IS TRUE THAT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
WAS CONSULTED WHEN SB 503 WAS
MOVING THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE.
AND TO THE BEST OF OUR
KNOWLEDGE, OUR REPLY WAS THAT WE
HAD NO CONCERNS IN OUR DEFENSE,
EXPERIENCE IS THE BEST TEACHER
AT THE TIME. OUR ELECTION STAFF
HAD NO EXPERIENCE REPORTING
LOCAL DATA OR TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR GATHERING IT.
WE NOW HAVE A THREE YEAR WINDOW
OF EXPERIENCE ON WHICH TO MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION. AS OF 2021, WE
HAD NONE. THIS MEASURE WILL
STREAMLINE THE REQUIREMENT TO BE
MORE IN LINE WITH OUR
TRADITIONAL REPORTING DUTIES. WE
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE IN THE HOPE
THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL SEE THE
WISDOM OF THIS APPROACH, RATHER
THAN HAVE OUR OFFICE CONTINUE TO
GATHER LOCAL DATA IN WHAT HAS
BEEN A SLOW AND AT TIMES
PIECEMEAL APPROACH. WITH THAT,
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. GOOD
MORNING. LARISSA MERCADO. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ELSA
SCHAEFER, MENLO PARK, IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WISHING
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION, SEEING
NONE. ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION. ALSO
SEEING NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? NOT SEEING ANY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR BILL AND
I INVITE YOU TO CLOSE, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HOPEFULLY
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. ALWAYS GOOD TO
SEE MY FRIEND ELSA SCHAEFER FROM
MENLO PARK. WASN'T EXPECTING
THAT. HAPPY TO SEE YOU IN SAC.
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR I VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON AB 3184? ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR SENATOR? MENGIBAR WAS
THERE AN EMOTION? THANK YOU,
THANK YOU SENATOR. SO THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS. BREAKSPEAR. AYE. WICKS
FOR AYE. ONE. ALAN MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE. NEWMAN PORTANTINO
UMBERG. 201. IT'S TWO ZERO, AND
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY MORE AUTHORS IN THE
ROOM. SO WE ARE GOING TO GO INTO
A RECESS UNTIL SOME OF THEM
COME.
WE ARE. ELECTION COMMITTEE IS
BACK. WE HAVE SENATOR ALLEN ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES-SAWYER FOR AB 3123. YOU
MAY PRESENT SENATOR. HEY. OKAY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'M PRESENTING THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOAN SAWYER, THE BILL
SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT ETHICS LAWS
THAT GOVERN ELECTED OFFICIALS
STATEWIDE APPLY EQUALLY TO THE
LA METRO BOARD OF DIRECTORS,
WITH THE RECENT PASSAGE OF SB
1439, WHICH AMENDED THE LEVINE
ACT IN 2023, CALIFORNIA MADE
CLEAR THAT THERE SHOULD BE A
UNIFORM ETHICS LAW GOVERNING
CONTRACT DECISIONS BY LOCAL AND
STATE OFFICIALS, REGARDLESS OF
THE COMPOSITION OF A BOARD OR
COMMISSION. HOWEVER, LA METRO IS
STILL SUBJECT TO A 30 YEAR OLD
LAW THAT IMPOSES DIFFERENT
STANDARDS ON BOARD MEMBERS
REGARDING CONTRACT DECISIONS AND
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS. JUST TO
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE, UNDER
CURRENT LAW, BOARD MEMBERS ARE
PROHIBITED FROM ACCEPTING
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS OVER $10,
BUT THE LEVINE ACT PROHIBITS
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS OVER
$250. THESE DIFFERING STANDARDS
AND REQUIREMENTS HAVE MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR LA METRO TO COMPLY
, SIMPLY BECAUSE BOARD MEMBERS
ARE SUBJECT TO BOTH THE LEVINE
ACT AND THE HAYDEN BILL IN THEIR
ROLES AS METRO BOARD MEMBERS.
IT'S BASICALLY A KIND OF A
CONFLICT OF LAWS. SO, LA METRO
IN THIS BILL IS SEEKING TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH ALL OTHER
OFFICIALS IN THE STATE, WHICH
MAKES CONTRACT, WHICH MAKING
CONTRACT DECISIONS UNDER THE
STANDARDS AND GUIDANCE OF THE
LEVINE ACT, WHICH GOVERNS THEIR
PRIMARY ELECTED POSITIONS, THIS
BILL WILL BRING THE METRO BOARD
INTO ALIGNMENT WITH THE LEVINE
ACT BY REMOVING OUT OF DATE
LANGUAGE ON GIFTS, HONORARIA,
TRAVEL, AND FINANCIAL CONFLICTS
THAT CONTRAST WITH CURRENT
APPLICABLE STATE LAW AND METRO'S
CODE OF CONDUCT. THE BILL ALSO
MAKES CHANGES TO METRO'S
LOBBYIST REGISTRATION STATUTE,
ALIGNING REPORTING REQUIREMENTS,
STANDARDS, AND PROHIBITIONS WITH
SIMILAR AGENCIES, AND CODIFIES
THE SPECIFIC AUTHORITY OF
METRO'S ETHICS DEPARTMENT AND
MANDATES ITS INDEPENDENCE. AND
HERE WITH ME, IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL, WE HAVE MADELEINE MOORE,
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR LA
METRO. EVERY TIME I SEE HER,
SHE'S BEEN PROMOTED TO SOMETHING
NEW, HIGHER AND HIGHER. AND THEN
PAUL SOLIS, WHO'S THE CHIEF
ETHICS OFFICER FOR LA METRO.
THANK YOU. YOU MAY PRESENT YOU
HAVE EACH LEAD WITNESSES. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. SENATOR
ALLEN. GOOD MORNING, VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS MADELEINE MOORE. I AM
HERE REPRESENTING LA METRO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS. LA METRO
IS THE PROUD SPONSOR OF AB 3123.
I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
PAUL SOLIS, LA METRO'S CHIEF
ETHICS OFFICER. WHO CAN GO INTO
GREATER DETAIL ABOUT THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS PAUL SOLIS, CHIEF ETHICS
OFFICER AT L.A. METRO. LA METRO
IS THE THIRD LARGEST
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN THE
UNITED STATES AND HAS ONE OF THE
LARGEST CAPITAL CONSTRUCTION AND
SYSTEM EXPANSION PROGRAMS IN THE
NATION. TO PREPARE FOR THE 2028
OLYMPICS AND BEYOND. I'M A BOARD
APPOINTED OFFICER AND MEMBER OF
THE STATE BAR OF CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY, I ADVISE THE LA METRO
BOARD ON ISSUES RELATED TO STATE
PAY TO PLAY LAWS. METRO IS
SUBJECT TO TWO OF THESE LAWS ONE
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE THAT
APPLIES EXCLUSIVELY TO METRO,
AND ONE OF THE GOVERNMENT CODE
KNOWN AS THE LEVINE ACT. THAT
APPLIES STATEWIDE. THE METRO
SPECIFIC PUC LAW EMPLOYS
DIFFERENT TERMS LANGUAGE, DOLLAR
THRESHOLDS AND TIME PERIODS THAN
THE LEVINE ACT. AND IMPORTANTLY,
THE LEVINE ACT HAS AMPLE
INTERPRETIVE INTERPRETIVE
GUIDANCE ISSUED BY THE FPPC AND
COURTS, WHILE THE PUC LAW HAS
VIRTUALLY NONE. THIS CREATES
ISSUES WITH COMPLIANCE, AND IT'S
FRANKLY VERY CONFUSING. IT ALSO
CREATES LIABILITY AND RISK FOR
METRO. THE CURRENT SPONSORED
AMENDMENTS WOULD ALLOW THE
LEVINE ACT TO GOVERN METRO. THE
METRO BOARDS PAY TO PLAY
RESPONSIBILITIES CONSISTENT WITH
ALL OTHER LOCAL AGENCIES IN THE
STATE, AND THE INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE AS EXPRESSED IN
2023, THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
ELEMENTS I WANT TO BRIEFLY
EXPLAIN. FIRST, THE BILL WOULD
MAKE AMENDMENTS TO METRO'S
LOBBYIST REGISTRATION STATUTE,
KEEPING IT CONSISTENT WITH ALL
OTHER JURISDICTIONS LIKE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES. NEXT, THE BILL
WOULD REMOVE OUT-OF-DATE
LANGUAGE IN THE BOARD'S CODE OF
CONDUCT. THAT CONTRASTS WITH
CURRENT APPLICABLE STATE LAW AND
METRO'S ADMINISTRATIVE CODES.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO ENACT
CHANGES IN ADDITIONS THAT EXIST
IN PEER AGENCY CODES. FINALLY,
THIS BILL STRENGTHENS METRO'S
ETHICS DEPARTMENT BY SPECIFYING
ITS AUTHORITY AND RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE BOARD AND AGENCY. IT
ALSO ADDS A TWO THIRDS VOTE
REQUIREMENT INSTEAD OF A SIMPLE
MAJORITY FOR THE BOARD TO FIRE
THE CHIEF ETHICS OFFICER, THE
SAME AS METRO'S INSPECTOR
GENERAL. THAT'S CURRENTLY
CODIFIED IN STATE LAW. IN
CONCLUSION, METRO IS SIMPLY
SIMPLY SEEKING TO IMPLEMENT A
CLEAR SYSTEM WHERE BOARD
MEMBERS, EMPLOYEES, LOBBYISTS,
AND CONTRACTORS CAN ALL HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY'RE
KNOWLEDGEABLE AND COMPLIANT WITH
IMPORTANT ETHICS LAWS AND RULES.
THUS, METRO SUPPORTS AB 3123.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU TO THE VICE
CHAIR FOR STARTING THIS. WE'LL
GO ON TO THE NEXT WITNESS. OH,
YOU ALREADY PRESENTED. OKAY.
THEN IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
OKAY? NOT SEEING ANY. IF THERE'S
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COME FORWARD AS LEAD
WITNESS, I DON'T SEE ANY ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. OKAY. DO NOT
SEE ANY, ANY. WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? OKAY. NOT SEEING ANY.
WE WILL TURN IT BACK TO YOU,
SENATOR ALLEN, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LET'S SEE. WE NEED,
OKAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR
MENGIBAR MOVES THE BILL, SO THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS BLAKE
SPEER, I WICKS BEER I11 NÓ ALLEN
I ALLEN I MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN. PORTANTINO UMBERG. THAT
IS THREE ONE AND WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON CALL. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE ARE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLL
AND LIFT THE CALL FOR ANY
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO VOTE.
LIFTING CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE AB
270. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ONE. CHAIR
VOTED AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTED NO.
ALLEN. OKAY, I'M REALLY SORRY
THAT THIS IS 270. YES. ALLEN I
NEWMAN. PORTANTINO UMBERG THREE
ONE. THREE ONE. WE WILL LEAVE IT
ON CALL LIFTING CALL ON FILE
ITEM SIX AB 2724. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ONE. CHAIR
VOTED AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTED NO.
ALLEN. ALLEN, Ã NEWMAN
PORTANTINO. UMBERG 3131. WE WILL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. LIFTING CALL
ON FILE ITEM 11 AB 3184. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 220. CHAIR VOTED
AYE WHEN ONE AYE. ALLEN ALLEN.
AYE. NEWMAN PORTANTINO. UMBERG
4040. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL
LIFTING. CALL ON CONSENT.
CALENDAR ITEM INCLUDES 2631.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO.
CHAIR VOTED AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTED AYE. ALLEN THIS IS. THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ALLEN I
NEWMAN. PORTANTINO UMBERG 4040.
WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL. THAT'S
ALL DONE. WE CAN LIFT. OKAY
THAT'S EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE
LIFTING AT THIS TIME. SO WE WILL
GO BACK TO A RECESS AND CALL ANY
AUTHORS WHO ARE NEEDING TO
PRESENT. PLEASE COME IMMEDIATELY
TO ROOM 2100. THANK YOU.
OKAY. THANK YOU FOR COMING TO
THE TWO AUTHORS WHO ARE HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VALENCIA. WHO IS NEXT IN
ORDER. THIS IS AB 2803, AND YOU
MAY PRESENT YOUR MEASURE.
GRACIAS, MADAM CHAIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, I AM HERE TO PRESENT AB
2803, WHICH RESTRICTS THE USE OF
CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR LEGAL DEFENSE
WHEN CANDIDATES AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS ARE CONVICTED OF
PUBLIC CRIMES OR FRAUD. IF A
CANDIDATE OR ELECTED OFFICIAL
USES CAMPAIGN FUNDS IN DEFENSE
OF THESE CHARGES, AND IS
CONVICTED, THEY MUST REIMBURSE
THE CAMPAIGN ACCOUNT. CAMPAIGN
DONORS EXPECT THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO BE USED TO
SUPPORT THEIR CANDIDATE OR
ELECTED OFFICIAL, BUT CURRENT
LAW LACKS CLARITY WHEN FUNDS ARE
USED FOR DISHONORABLE LEGAL
CASES. ELECTED OFFICIALS CHARGED
WITH THESE CRIMES NOT ONLY
BETRAY THE PUBLIC'S TRUST, BUT
ALSO UNDERMINE DONOR INTEGRITY
BY USING THOSE DONATIONS TO
FIGHT IMMORAL CHARGES. WHILE IN
PUBLIC OFFICE, CANDIDATES ARE
ALREADY PROHIBITED FROM RUNNING
FOR OFFICE IF THEY ARE CONVICTED
OF PUBLIC CRIMES, SO THERE IS NO
REASON WHY THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO USE CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS AND DONATIONS ON
CONVICTED CHARGES. FELONY FRAUD
CHARGES ALSO REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT BREACH OF CONFIDENCE
, REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
FRAUD CHARGES, SINCE IT
DEMONSTRATES THE LACK OF MORAL
CHARACTER OF THE CANDIDATE AND
ELECTED OFFICIAL. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS ANY, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? I DO NOT.
OKAY. ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT? OKAY
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES WISHING
TO COME FORWARD, NOT SEEING ANY
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM,
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION,
NOT SEEING ANY. WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. I DO NOT
SEE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS,
BUT I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD AND
WHEN WE GET TO THE APPROPRIATE
TIME, WE WILL ACCEPT A MOTION.
BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
THIS HAS BEEN SUPPORTED BY
THROUGH BIPARTISAN PARTNERSHIP.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES
VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. IT IS
ACTUALLY NOT TECHNICALLY ON CALL
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT HAD A MOTION
YET. BUT YOU DON'T NEED TO STAY.
ALL RIGHT. SO OUR NEXT BILL IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKINNON AB2911.
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
WELL, GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR,
AB 2009 11 WILL DISCOURAGE THE
USE OF DARK MONEY IN LOCAL
ELECTIONS AND EASE SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL BURDENS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BY REVISING THE
LEVIN'S ACT'S ARBITRARILY LOW
CONTRIBUTION LIMIT, A LIMIT THAT
HAS NOT BEEN CHANGED IN OVER 40
YEARS. CURRENT LAW SEVERELY
LIMITS A LOCAL CANDIDATE. LOCAL
CANDIDATES ABILITY TO RUN A
COMPETITIVE CAMPAIGN,
COMMUNICATE DIRECTLY WITH
VOTERS, AND HAS RESULTED IN AN
INCREASED USE OF NON-CANDIDATE
CONTROL. INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURE
FINANCED WITH DARK MONEY. Ã
2021 STUDY PUBLISHED IN THE
AMERICAN ECONOMIC JOURNAL
APPLIED ECONOMICS, CONCLUDED
THAT POLITICS THAT SET LOW
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS REDUCED THE
CONCENTRATION OF POLITICAL POWER
IN THE HANDS OF RICHER
INDIVIDUALS. ADDITIONALLY, IN
JUST THE PAST TWO YEARS,
COMPLIANCE WITH SB 1439 HAS COST
LOCAL GOVERNMENT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE
BETTER SPENT SUPPORTING LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY PROGRAMS,
INFRASTRUCTURE, OR EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. SIMILAR
LEGISLATION HAS HEARD HAS BEEN
HEARD BY THIS COMMITTEE EARLIER
THIS YEAR, AND I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH SENATOR DODD AND
GLAZIER TO RESOLVE ANY REMAINING
CONFLICTS WITH THEIR LEGISLATION
BEFORE THE BILLS ARE VOTED ON BY
THE FULL SENATE AND ASSEMBLY.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
2911 IS MARCEL RODARTE,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
CONTRACT CITIES ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU. YES, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
I'LL BE QUICK. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING. DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE ELECTIONS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MARCEL
RODARTE. I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONTRACT CITIES ASSOCIATION. WE
REPRESENT 81 CITIES AND NEARLY
EIGHT 8 MILLION RESIDENTS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 29 BY AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA SINCE
1957. CONTRACT CITIES HAS BEEN
DEDICATED TO PROMOTING THE
INTERESTS OF OUR CITIES AND
RESIDENTS. AND TODAY, I'M PROUD
TO CONTINUE THAT TRADITION. AB
2911 SEEKS TO INCREASE THE
LIVING ACT FROM $250 TO $1500.
THIS INCREASE IS CRUCIAL AS
TODAY'S LOW CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
CANDIDATES WITH LIMITED PERSONAL
FINANCES, CREATING NEW BARRIERS
FOR LOW INCOME CANDIDATES SHOULD
THEY WANT TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
THIS DISPARITY UNDERMINES
PRINCIPLES OF FAIRNESS AND
EQUALITY IN OUR ELECTORAL
PROCESS. THERE SHOULD BE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANY QUALIFYING
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT TO RUN FOR
OFFICE IF THEY WISH TO DO SO.
NOTABLY, CONTRACT CITIES IS
GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
RESPONSIBLE CAMPAIGN CAMPAIGN
FINANCE REFORMS FOR ELECTED
OFFICIALS AT BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS. HOWEVER, WE DO NOT
FEEL THE CURRENT LIMITS
ESTABLISHED BY THE LIVING ACT
OFFER SUCH A FRAMEWORK. INSTEAD,
ITS CURRENT POLICIES HAVE
INADVERTENTLY CREATED MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DARK MONEY AND
LOCAL POLITICS CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT WOULD TYPICALLY GO TO
CANDIDATES CAMPAIGNS ARE NOW
MORE LIKELY TO BE REDIRECTED TO
INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURES, AND
OTHER THIRD PARTY CAMPAIGNS,
MAKING THE MONEY HARDER TO
FOLLOW, INCREASING THE
CONTRIBUTION LIMIT TO $1,500
WOULD NOT ONLY PROMOTE MORE
DIRECT CONTRIBUTIONS, BUT THE
POLICY CHANGE WILL ALSO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN CAMPAIGN FINANCING AND
STRENGTHEN OUR DEMOCRACY
TOGETHER, WE CAN ENSURE THAT ALL
CANDIDATES HAVE A FAIR CHANCE TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR DEMOCRACY,
REGARDLESS OF THEIR FINANCIAL
STATUS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER TO ADVANCE THE
INTERESTS OF OUR CITIES AND
RESIDENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL MAY COME FORWARD. STATE
YOUR NAME, ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR, NORLAND
ASHBROOK WITH AXIOM ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MACKAY
CARNEY, ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY, IN SUPPORT DYLAN ELLIOTT
ON BEHALF OF THE FRESNO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, JOHNNY PENA WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NICOLE
WATERMAN WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE THERE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WISHING TO COME FORWARD?
STILL. GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH. THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU, CHAIR MEMBERS,
I'M PEDRO FERNANDEZ, ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE. WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
WE WERE STRONG SUPPORTERS OF SB
1439. THE GLAZER BILL, WHICH
EXTENDED THE LEVINE ACT
PROVISIONS TO ELECTED LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS. AND WHILE WE
DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
PREVIOUS AMENDMENTS THAT GREATLY
REDUCE THE SCOPE OF THE BILL, WE
STILL THINK THE THRESHOLD IS TOO
HIGH. FIRST, THE ANALYSIS OF THE
BILL NOTES THAT CHANGING THE
CONTRIBUTION LIMIT TO TWO FROM
250 TO 1500 IS AN INCREASE OF
500. WE BELIEVE THAT SOLELY
MODIFYING THE CONTRIBUTION LIMIT
TO $1,500 DOES NOT FURTHER THE
INTEREST OF COMBATING CORRUPTION
IN THE AND ITS APPEARANCE, AND
WOULD AND WOULD NOT FURTHER THE
PURPOSES OF THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT. WE WANT TO NOTE THAT THERE
ARE TWO OTHER BILLS THAT ARE
BEING CONSIDERED THAT ARE
CONSIDERING A MODIFICATION TO
THE CONTRIBUTION THRESHOLD, AND
IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS, WE HAVE
EXPRESSED RECOGNITION THAT THE
CONTRIBUTION LIMIT COULD BE
RAISED. HOWEVER 1500 IS TOO
HIGH, THAT AMOUNT WOULD EXCEED
MOST INDIVIDUAL CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS FOR INDIVIDUALS, LET
ALONE INTERESTED PARTIES WITH
PENDING BUSINESS BEFORE A LOCAL
BOARD OR COUNCIL. WE BELIEVE
THAT A TIERED SYSTEM LIKE THE
ONE OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS
ACKNOWLEDGES AT LEAST
ACKNOWLEDGES THE FACT THAT
CAMPAIGN FINANCES DIFFER BETWEEN
SMALL AND LARGE CITIES. IN FACT,
THIS CONCEPT WAS ENDORSED IN A
RECENT EDITORIAL IN THE PRESS
DEMOCRAT THAT DREW COMPARISONS
BETWEEN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
AND THE CITY OF HEALDSBURG. IF
THE BILL IS NOT AMENDED TODAY,
WE THINK THE APPROPRIATE FORUM
TO MAKE MODIFICATIONS TO THE
THRESHOLD IS IN THE CONTEXT OF
ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS AND THE TWO
OTHER SENATE BILLS THAT SEEK TO
IMPROVE COMPLIANCE AND ADDRESSES
WORKLOAD CONCERNS. THANK YOU
CHAIR. THANK YOU, COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR YOUR CAREFUL ATTENTION
TO THESE MATTERS. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NAY VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING AGAIN, CHAIR BLAKE
SPEER. AND MEMBERS, TRENT LANG,
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN. I ALSO SPEAK TO
YOU IN RESPECTFUL BUT STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB 2911. UNLESS
IT'S AMENDED, $1,500 IS JUST TOO
HIGH. IT'S A 500% INCREASE FROM
THE $250 LIMIT. THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED ONLY TWO YEARS AGO FOR
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
DEVELOPERS, CITY CONTRACTORS AND
OTHER SPECIAL INTERESTS CAN GIVE
TO LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS WHEN
THEY'RE DECIDING ON THEIR
APPLICATIONS. A RELATIVELY LOW
LEVINE ACT LIMIT GIVES VOTERS
CONFIDENCE THAT THERE ISN'T PAY
TO PLAY $1,500 DEFINITELY DOES
NOT. WE HAVE DATA ON THIS. WE
RECENTLY COMPLETED A POLL OF 837
LIKELY NOVEMBER 2024. CALIFORNIA
VOTERS THAT ASKED, HOW CONCERNED
WOULD YOU BE IF THE CONTRIBUTION
LIMIT THAT PARTIES, PARTICIPANTS
AND THEIR AGENTS CAN GIVE TO
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS WHILE
THEY'RE CONSIDERING THE
PROPOSALS, SUCH AS DEVELOPMENT
AGREEMENTS, WERE INCREASED, 81%
OF LIKELY VOTERS SAID THEY'D BE
CONCERNED IF THE LIMIT WAS
RAISED TO $1,500. 50% SAID
THEY'D BE VERY CONCERNED. $500
WAS THE ONLY LEVEL OF POLL
TESTED AT WHICH MORE VOTERS SAID
THEY WOULDN'T BE CONCERNED THAN
WHO SAID THEY WOULD BE VERY
CONCERNED. SO WE BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION TO
SET A TIERED THRESHOLD OF $500
FOR JURISDICTIONS WITH A
POPULATION OF $50,000 OR MORE,
WHILE LEAVING IT AT $250 FOR
SMALLER CITIES, STRIKES A PROPER
BALANCE, AND WE THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THIS
RECOMMENDATION. REFERRING TO
THAT EDITORIAL, $250 MAY NOT BE
MUCH IN LARGE CITIES, BUT IN
CITIES LIKE HEALDSBURG, WITH A
POPULATION OF ONLY 11,000,
THAT'S A LOT. AND THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF SUCH SMALL CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. IF THE AUTHOR
DOESN'T ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENT, THEN WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO. THERE ARE TWO
BILLS IN THE SENATE THAT
SERIOUSLY ADDRESS IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES WITH LEVINE ACT, AND WITH
A NUMBER OF POSITIVE AMENDMENTS
THAT MAKE COMPLIANCE EASIER AND
NARROW ITS SCOPE TO THE KINDS OF
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE THE
GREATEST CONCERNS THIS BILL
DOES. NONE OF THESE THINGS. SO
UNLESS IT'S AMENDED, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
JEFF TARDAGUILA, AN ADVOCATE,
UNLESS, AMENDMENTS ARE MADE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. CRAIG
DUNKERLEY, SAN JOSE IN
OPPOSITION, UNLESS AMENDED. ALL
RIGHT. JOHN FIORETTI, SAN JOSE,
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU
. MERRILEES LEEB, MOUNTAIN VIEW
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED.
CHRISTINE AIKEN TRACY IN
OPPOSITION, UNLESS AMENDED.
CAROL BADGER, SAN FRANCISCO
OBJECT TO ANY AMOUNT. THANK YOU.
CATHERINE ESPITIA TRACY.
CALIFORNIA. OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. ELSA SHAFER, MENLO PARK
. OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED, PER
THE AMENDMENTS. WE'VE HEARD
TODAY. ELAINE EL-BIZRI, PALO
ALTO OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED.
EDITH JACOBY, PALO ALTO OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED. I'M ALAN BRINKER
FROM SUNNYVALE. I'M A GENERAL
CONTRACTOR AND BUILDER, AND
UNLESS IT'S AMENDED, I STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT BECAUSE I KNOW HOW THE
GAME IS PLAYED 42 YEARS. JIM
DAVIDSON, LOS ALTOS OPPOSE,
UNLESS AMENDED. NANCY NEFF, PALO
ALTO. OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED.
KELLY CUTHBERTSON, OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. VICKI
MUELLER, OLVERA, SAN JOSE.
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED. KARLA
KINCAID, YOSHIKAWA, SAN
FRANCISCO, OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED. I CAME IN BECAUSE OF AB
270 TODAY, AND I'M. I WANT TO
SAY I'M STRONGLY IN SUPPORT AND
NOTING ALL OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT FOR IT. THANK YOU. DAVID
SCHMIDT, SAN FRANCISCO, OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. MARY GILL,
STANFORD OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
CAROL CROSS ALSO OPPOSED, UNLESS
IT'S AMENDED. REDWOOD CITY.
GRAHAM HEWIT WALNUT CREEK
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED. CYNTHIA
SHALIT ON BEHALF OF THE 60
CHAPTERS OF INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG
THROUGHOUT THE CHAPTERS ARE
ACROSS THE STATE AND ALSO
CALIFORNIA. INDIVISIBLE GREEN
TEAM. THANK YOU. IN OPPOSITION.
AMY HUI, WALNUT CREEK OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. RALPH HENLEY,
SAN JOSE OPPOSED UNLESS
RECOMMENDED. JOE ELY, BRENTWOOD
CONTRA CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED. SHANNON
GEIST, CALIFORNIA. CLEAN MONEY,
SAN FRANCISCO YOU REPRESENT THE
PEOPLE AND NOT BUSINESS. SUSAN
PELIKAN, WOODLAND, CALIFORNIA.
YOLO INDIVISIBLE. OPPOSED.
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU.
LAWRENCE ABBOTT, SAN LEANDRO.
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. SHIRLEY
KALINOWSKI, PLEASANT HILL.
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED AS STATED
SHIRLEY MCGRATH, WALNUT CREEK
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED. CRAIG
DUNKERLEY, ON BEHALF OF LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS. COURAGE,
CALIFORNIA. CONSUMER WATCHDOG
AND ENDANGERED HABITATS LEAGUE.
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED. WELL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO EVERYBODY
WHO TOOK YOUR TIME TO COME AND
EXPRESS YOUR POSITION TODAY. WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE HEARING IT.
I WILL TURN IT BACK TO THE
AUTHOR. WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY
ANYTHING IN RESPONSE TO THE
OPPOSITION? YES I LOOKED AT SOME
OF THE AMENDMENTS, SUGGESTED. IT
LOOKS LIKE, THE AMENDMENT SAYS
50. IF WE HAVE A POPULATION OF
50,000 OR MORE, WE YOU WOULD BE
WILLING TO RAISE IT UP TO 500.
IS THAT RIGHT? WELL, I'D LIKE TO
SAY THAT IN L.A. COUNTY. FIRST,
LET ME START WITH EACH, LOCAL
CONTROL, EACH CITY AND COUNTY
WOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE IN THEIR CITY OR COUNTY
WHERE PEOPLE CAN, GO INTO THEIR
CITY OR COUNTY AND MAKE THEIR
OBJECTIONS. THEY WOULD HAVE
LOCAL CONTROL RATHER TO KEEP IT
AT 250 OR RAISE IT UP TO 1500,
AND WE KNOW THAT, LOCAL LOCAL
CONTROL IS VERY IMPORTANT. AND
WE KNOW THAT COMMUNITIES CAN GO
OUT AND SPEAK FOR HAVE A VOICE
BECAUSE AS WE COULD SEE, THAT
ALL THE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE WERE NOT REPRESENTED HERE
TODAY AND COMMUNITIES WOULD
ACTUALLY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GO TO THEIR CITY COUNCIL PEOPLE
AND GO WHERE THEY ELECT THEM AND
GO TO THEIR COUNTIES WHERE THEY
ELECT THEM AND, AND, AND, AND,
TALK TO THEM TO ABOUT KEEPING IT
AT 250 OR RAISING IT TO 1500.
SECONDLY $1,500 IS WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO COMMUNICATE WITH
FOLKS. WE HAVE 10 MILLION PEOPLE
IN L.A. COUNTY, TOO MANY 2
MILLION PER SUPERVISOR. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE IN L.A. COUNTY THAT
AN L.A. COUNTY IS ONE OF THE
MOST PROGRESSIVE COUNTIES IN THE
STATE. IT IS THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE COUNTY IN THE STATE.
WE'RE PROUD OF THAT. BUT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN KEEP
THOSE TYPE OF LEGISLATORS. AND
WHAT HAPPENS IS, IF WE IF WE
KEEP IT AT 250, DARK MONEY WILL
COME IN. I'M A TREASURER BY
TRADE AS WELL. DARK MONEY WILL
COME INTO THESE RACES AND THEY
WILL PUT SO MUCH MONEY AGAINST
OUR PROGRESSIVE FOLKS, BECAUSE
OUR PROGRESSIVE FOLKS ARE
USUALLY NOT WEALTHY PEOPLE. AND
SO ALL THIS MONEY WOULD COME
STORMING INTO INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURES WHERE IT'S VERY
HARD TO TRACK. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE COMMUNITY CAN
TRACK THOSE, THOSE THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS DIRECTLY. THAT'S
GOING TO THOSE ELECTED
OFFICIALS. AND IF WE ALLOW ALLOW
THIS ALL TO GO INTO DARK MONEY,
IF WE ALLOW, IF WE JUST ONLY
ACCEPT $250 IN THOSE CITIES LIKE
LA AND THOSE STATES LIKE LA
COUNTY, THOSE, SUPERVISOR
COUNTIES LIKE LA, LA COUNTY,
DARK MONEY WILL FLOW IN THERE
AND WE WILL NOT WE WILL LOSE OUR
PROGRESSIVE LEADER. SO I AM
ASKING FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO
VOTE AYE. AND I WILL WORK ON THE
TIERED SYSTEM. I DON'T THINK
THAT THIS IS I DON'T THINK THIS
GOES, THIS IS FAIR. AND SO I
LOOKED AT THE TIER SYSTEM. I
HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS TO OFFER UP
IF THIS COMMITTEE PASSES THIS
BILL, I WILL WORK, WORK ON THOSE
TIER SYSTEMS GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU.
WELL, SO I'LL JUST MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS HERE. SO FIRST OF ALL,
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT ALLOW FOR AN
ELECTION THAT WOULD OVERTURN THE
LEVINE ACT IN THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES. SO THE LEVINE
ACT, IF THE BILL PASSES, WOULD
APPLY A $1,500 STANDARD AND THE
$1,500 STANDARD APPLIES TO THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THERE IS A
DONATION THAT IS MADE BY AN
APPLICANT OR AN APPLICANT'S
AGENT, FOR A PERMIT IN FRONT OF
THAT BODY. SO THIS IS NOT WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT EVERY CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION THAT PEOPLE MAKE
DURING ELECTIONS. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCE
OF WHEN THERE'S A DECISION
THAT'S IN FRONT OF A BODY AND
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING THAT
DECISION COULD RECEIVE A DIRECT
AMOUNT. SO THE CURRENT LAW IS
THAT THEY CAN RECEIVE 250 UP TO
$250 FROM THE APPLICANT OR THE
AGENTS OF THE APPLICANT, AND
THIS WOULD RAISE THAT TO 1500.
SO I RECOGNIZE THAT THE AUTHOR
IS REPRESENTING THE LARGEST CITY
IN THE STATE, LOS ANGELES. BUT
THERE ARE 400 PLUS OTHER CITIES
AND JURISDICTIONS, SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THAT THIS HIGHER
THRESHOLD WOULD APPLY TO. I COME
FROM HAVING BEEN THE MAYOR OF A
CITY THAT WAS JUST OVER 60,000
PEOPLE, AND WE HAD A $250
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMIT, AND
I BELIEVE THAT $1,500 WOULD
INFLUENCE ELECTIONS, WOULD
INFLUENCE DECISION MAKERS IN
WAYS THAT WE THAT WOULD NOT
PROMOTE THE PUBLIC'S INTEREST.
SO I AM NOT SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. TODAY. I WAS RECOMMENDING
THE TIERS OF THE $500 AND THE
250, WHICH IS RECOMMENDED IN THE
STAFF REPORT TO RECOGNIZE SOME
CITIES ARE BIGGER THAN A CITY
LIKE THAT. I CAME FROM. BUT I
ALSO FEEL LIKE, FURTHERING THE
INTEREST, THE ANTICORRUPTION
INTERESTS, THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE
ARE CONTRIBUTING TO THOSE WHO
ARE DIRECTLY MAKING A DECISION
ABOUT THEM WITHIN THAT YEAR
PERIOD. TO ME, THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE AS ELECTED OFFICIALS
WITH A PUBLIC CHARGE, NEED TO
TAKE SERIOUSLY AND NEED TO VOTE
IN FAVOR OF THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
SO THE ARGUMENT THAT MONEY, DARK
MONEY IS FLOWING INTO WHAT'S
CALLED INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURES
OR IES THAT WILL OVERWHELM, WILL
OVERWHELM ELECTIONS IS A
CONCERN. AND I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE REFORMS AROUND INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURES. BUT THE REALITY OF
SETTING UP INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURES IS THAT YOU HAVE TO
BE WILLING TO HAVE A LEVEL OF
SOPHISTICATION AND GO THROUGH
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A COMMITTEE
TO HAVE THE DONORS TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF DOING THAT. AND
IF YOU'RE AN INDIVIDUAL PERSON
WHO'S TRYING TO, LET'S SAY,
MODIFY YOUR HOME AND YOU WANT A
BUILDING PERMIT THAT MIGHT MAKE
CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS THAT COULD
NEGATIVELY AFFECT YOUR
NEIGHBORS, THAT KIND OF RUN OF
THE MILL DECISION THAT A LOT OF
CITY COUNCILS ARE MAKING. THAT
KIND OF DECISION IS NOT GOING TO
LEAD TO AN INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURE BEING SET UP. IT'S
SOMETHING WHERE SOMEBODY MIGHT
CULTIVATE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THOSE ON THE CITY COUNCIL, AND
THEN THEY WOULD MAKE MAXIMUM
CONTRIBUTIONS. AND WHEN YOU HAVE
1500 TIMES THE AGENTS TIMES THE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS WITH THAT
PERSON'S BUSINESS OR WHATNOT, I,
I CAN FORESEE SITUATIONS WHERE
THE DECISION MAKERS ARE
INFLUENCED BY THAT MONEY. SO TO
ME, IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
KEEP THE AMOUNT LOW AND WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
CHANGES IN THE INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURE THAT THE DARK MONEY,
THE MONEY THAT IS ABLE TO GO
INTO THESE OTHER TYPES OF
ACCOUNTS. BUT I ALSO THINK THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENT REFORMS THAT
ARE NEEDED IN ORDER TO MAKE THE
PROCESS EASIER TO MANAGE FOR
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND FOR CITY
ATTORNEYS WHO ARE TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS. SO THIS BILL
THAT PASSED TWO YEARS AGO IS NOT
STATIC. THIS ISN'T THE ONLY
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT IT. BUT AT THIS
POINT, I AM NOT GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL, AND I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT I
CLEARLY EXPLAINED TO EVERYBODY
WHY THAT IS. NOW, IF THE AUTHOR
WOULD LIKE ME TO TAKE A RECESS
IN LIGHT OF THE TESTIMONY AND
TALK AGAIN ABOUT THIS BILL, I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH YOU RIGHT NOW ABOUT IT. BUT
IF NOT, WE'LL PROCEED AHEAD, AS
WE'VE BEEN DOING, BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT, YOU ARE NOT ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS, AND SO YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROCEED WITH THE BILL AS
IT IS. SO I WOULD LEAVE THAT UP
TO YOU. EXCUSE ME. YES, I'M
GOING TO PROCEED WITH THE BILL
AS IS. AND TO CLOSE, I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH THE
COUNTIES, YOU'RE NOT JUST
DEALING WITH YOU'RE DEALING WITH
NONPROFITS THAT DO REALLY,
REALLY GOOD WORK OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND THEY ALSO CAN'T
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR A
NONPROFIT, YOU ALSO CAN'T GIVE
TO YOUR COUNTY SUPERVISOR
BECAUSE YOU DO BUSINESS WITH THE
COUNTY. AND A LOT OF THESE
NONPROFITS DO REALLY, REALLY
GOOD WORK. IT'S ALREADY ILLEGAL
TO DO PAY TO PLAY. THAT IS
ILLEGAL ALREADY. WE DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT THAT. BUT YOU
KNOW, YOU ENTRUST $5,500
DONATIONS TO US TO STATE
OFFICIALS, $5,500. THAT IS WAY
MORE THAN 1500. AND YOU'RE
TRUSTING US BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE
WHO RUN FOR OFFICE ARE NOT
RUNNING FOR OFFICE TO DO
ANYTHING BAD, TO BE CORRUPT
MOST. AND IF YOU ARE CORRUPT, WE
HAVE. WE'VE STOPPED THAT TOO.
WE'VE STOPPED THAT TOO. THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO'VE GOTTEN IN
TROUBLE FOR DOING THESE TYPES OF
THINGS. AND SO FROM THERE I WILL
SAY MOST ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT
RUN ARE NOT TRYING TO BE
CORRUPT. WE AT THE STATE, WE
ACCEPT $5,500 AND YOU GUYS TRUST
US. AND SO WITH THAT, I WOULD
ASK THIS COMMITTEE FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK
YOU. WE DON'T HAVE ANY MOTION AT
THIS POINT. SO IF SOMEBODY, IF
WE MAKE A MOTION LATER, THEN
THEN THERE WILL BE A VOTE. SO
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU AGAIN,
TO EVERYBODY WHO CAME FOR THIS.
OKAY. OUR NEXT ITEM IS. LET ME
SEE. OKAY OKAY. OUR NEXT ITEM IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO'S AB
3239. AND WE INVITE YOU TO COME
FORWARD AND PRESENT YOUR MEASURE
.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS, PROUD TO PRESENT AB
20. SORRY. PROUD TO PRESENT AB
3239. THIS DESK IS SO LOW, IT'S
GOTTA BRING THINGS UP, WHICH
WOULD PERMIT CAMPAIGN FUNDS TO
BE USED TO PAY OR REIMBURSE
AIRLINE TRAVEL EXPENSES RELATED
TO AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT ANIMAL
BELONGING TO AND TRAVELING WITH
AN INDIVIDUAL WHOSE TRAVEL IS
AUTHORIZED TO BE PAID USING
CAMPAIGN FUNDS. WE OFTEN DISCUSS
THE IMPORTANCE OF MENTAL HEALTH,
THE LACK OF ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES, BUT WE FIND
OURSELVES FIGHTING AGAINST
SYSTEMS THAT DON'T SUPPORT
ACTUAL MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
UP UNTIL 2021, THIS LAW WOULD
NOT EVEN HAVE BEEN NEEDED, AND A
DOCTOR'S NOTE WAS NEEDED TO
ALLOW AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
ANIMAL TO BE EXEMPT FROM TRAVEL
FEES. THAT CAN RANGE FROM
ANYWHERE BETWEEN 100 AND 20 5 TO
$175 PER ONE WAY TRAVEL. THIS
POLICY CHANGED IN 2021 ON A
FEDERAL LEVEL, AND THE COST
ASSOCIATED FOR ANYONE TRAVELING
WITH AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT ANIMAL
BECAME THAT OF THE INDIVIDUAL.
THE PRESENCE OF AN EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL CAN CAUSE CALMING
EFFECTS TO AN INDIVIDUAL AT
WORK. AT SCHOOL, AND IN EVERYDAY
LIFE EXPERIENCES. THIS BILL
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION.
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS AN I VOTE.
OKAY. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? NO. OKAY.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT? SEEING NONE.
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WISHING TO COME
FORWARD? SEEING NONE. DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION? I SEE NONE. SO WE
WILL KEEP THIS BILL OPEN. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
OH, WAIT. I'M SORRY. WE'LL ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN I VOTE, MADAM CHAIR.
OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SURVIVE THIS. SHE'S GOING TO
PRESENT THIS RIGHT AS WELL. OKAY
.
OKAY. THIS IS AB 2951 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CARRILLO WILL
BE PRESENTING IT. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS AND COMMITTEE, THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 2951 ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE, ASSEMBLYWOMAN
CERVANTES, WE WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED ON PAGE
FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS AND ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH HER TEAM AND THE
SPONSORS. ASSEMBLY BILL 2951 IS
A FOLLOW UP TO ASSEMBLY BILL
2841 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER, LOW IN
2022. WE WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWS IS ALSO A
JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS PARTICULAR
POLICY. AB 2841 WENT INTO EFFECT
ON JANUARY 1ST OF THIS YEAR.
AMONG OTHER PROVISIONS, AB 2841
SET OUT A NEW PROCEDURE FOR
HANDLING THE CANCELLATION OF
VOTER REGISTRATION DUE TO
SEVERAL SITUATIONS, INCLUDING
THE DEATH OF A VOTER, A CHANGE
IN THE RESIDENCY OR IMPRISONMENT
DUE TO CONVICTION OF A FELONY.
HOWEVER, DUE TO DELAYS IN THE
UPGRADING OF VOTE, CAL
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE DATABASE OF
REGISTERED VOTERS, THE
SECRETARY'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
UNABLE TO IMPLEMENT SOME
PROVISIONS OF AB 2841. IN A
TIMELY MANNER. IN PARTICULAR,
THE SECRETARY'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
UNABLE TO COMPLY WITH THE
PROVISIONS OF AB 2841 REGARDING
REGARDING VOTERS WHOSE
REGISTRATION IS CANCELED DUE TO
DEATH. AB 2951 WOULD EXTEND THE
DEADLINE TO COMPLY WITH THAT
PARTICULAR PROVISION OF AB 2841
UNTIL JULY 1ST OF 2025. THE
SECRETARY OF STATE BELIEVES THAT
THIS EXTENSION WILL PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT TIME TO ENSURE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION, AS INTENDED BY
THE LEGISLATURE ON AB 2841 HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS TIM CROMARTIE. ON BEHALF
OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE,
DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER, AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS TIM CARMODY,
SECRETARY OF STATE JULIAN
WEBBER'S OFFICE AGAIN. I ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE HARD WORK AND
PERSEVERANCE THAT BROUGHT US TO
THIS POINT. THIS MEASURE DELAYS
IMPLEMENTATION ON ONE NARROW
ASPECT OF AB 2841, WHICH
REGULATES DISQUALIFICATION FROM
VOTING. AND AGAIN, AS IT'S BEEN
STATED, THIS IS PRIMARILY DUE TO
THE COMPLEXITY AND TIME
CONSUMING NATURE OF THE REQUIRED
UPGRADES TO THE VOTE CAL SYSTEM,
THE STATE'S VOTER REGISTRATION
DATABASE, TO ENSURE FULL
COMPLIANCE. NONETHELESS, OUR
ELECTIONS DIVISION, AFTER A
MAJOR EFFORT HAS IMPLEMENTED
MOST AB 2841 PROVISIONS THROUGH
A MANUAL PROCESS, AND THEY
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARD FULL
IMPLEMENTATION BY JULY OF 2025.
THIS MEASURE WILL BRING THE LAW
INTO LINE WITH THE COMPLETION
DATE THAT OUR STAFF DETERMINED
AS OF 2022, WOULD BE FEASIBLE.
AND BASED ON THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY THEM AND ASSUMING NO
INTERVENING UNFORESEEN
CIRCUMSTANCES, WE'RE CONFIDENT
THAT THE SECRETARY'S OFFICE CAN
ACHIEVE FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF
AB 2841 BY JULY 1ST, 2025, AND
AS A FINAL NOTE, I'D JUST LIKE
TO SAY THAT WE'RE CONCERNED,
HOWEVER, ABOUT ONE OF THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. WE DON'T
TAKE ISSUE WITH THEM. WE DON'T
WANT TO UPSET THE APPLE CART AT
THIS POINT, BUT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT ONE OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS PERTAINING TO A
REPORTING REQUIREMENT. WE WOULD
PREFER TO HAVE THAT LANGUAGE
SOFTENED TO REQUIRE PERIODIC
UPDATES AS OPPOSED TO FORMAL
REPORTS TO THE LEGISLATURE, ONLY
BECAUSE THE LATTER MAY SLOW OUR
EFFORTS IN IMPLEMENTATION. WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT? GOOD
AFTERNOON. NOW I THINK NOW
AFTERNOON, LARA MERCADO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I THINK
IT'S STILL IT'S 1146. CLOSE.
YES. GETTING AHEAD OF MYSELF.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT? OKAY. ANYBODY WISHING
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION, LEAD
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION MAY
COME FORWARD NOT SEEING ANY. WE
WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM, NOT SEEING ANY. BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS? OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL
TURN IT BACK TO YOU. TO CLOSE,
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN. YES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. OKAY. WITH
THIS, WE WILL GO BACK TO A
RECESS. THANK YOU.
OKAY. WE ARE COMING BACK FROM
RECESS TO DO, TO LIFT THE CALL
ON VOTES AND ALSO TO TAKE
MOTIONS. SO WHICH ONE ARE WE
STARTING WITH? A ÁP. WE'RE
STARTING WITH AB 2803. FILE ITEM
SEVEN. IS THERE A MOTION ON THIS
BILL? YES. SO MOTION. THERE WAS
A MOTION BY SENATOR ALLEN AND
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS BLAKE
SPEAR A SPEAR I WHEN I, WHEN I
ALLEN ALLEN I MENGIBAR NEWMAN
PORTANTINO UMBERG THREE ZERO
IT'S THREE ZERO. WE WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL. WHAT'S THE NEXT
ONE? EIGHT 2911. OKAY. NEXT IS
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB 2911 FROM
MCKENNA. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
OKAY. SEEING NO MOTION, WE WILL
GO TO THE NEXT ITEM. ITEM NINE
AB 2951 CERVANTES, SO MOVED.
THIS IS DO PASS, AS AMENDED. BY
ITEM NINE, AB 2951. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
BLAKESPEAR AYE AYE AYE ONE. NO
ONE. NO ALAN. ALLEN. AYE.
MENGIBAR NEWMAN. PORTANTINO.
UMBERG TWO ONE. THAT'S TWO. ONE.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL. ARE WE
GOING ON TO NUMBER 1012 MOTION
GOING ON TO 12. OKAY. WE'RE ON
TO FILE ITEM 12 AB 3239 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. AND WE WOULD NEED
A MOTION FOR THAT OKAY. SO
THERE'S NO MOTION ON THAT. WE
WILL KEEP THAT ON CALL. YEAH I'M
NOT VOTING.
OKAY. WE ARE COMING BACK FROM
RECESS. AND BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
SUMMER RECESS HERE. THIS IS
ACTUALLY OUR LAST SCHEDULED
POLICY HEARING. SO I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THIS. THIS
IS YOUR THE LAST REGULARLY
SCHEDULED ELECTIONS COMMITTEE,
SO, AS YOU MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW,
EVERYBODY, SENATOR PORTANTINO
WOULD ASK TRIVIA QUESTIONS WHEN
HE WAS IN HIS ROLE AS THE CHAIR
OF COMMITTEES. SO I HAVE A
COUPLE I HAVE THREE VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
OKAY. SO IN WHAT YEAR DID
CALIFORNIA VOTERS APPROVE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS OF
INITIATIVE, REFERENDUM AND
RECALL? 72? NO, IT WAS FAR
BEFORE THAT. GUESS AGAIN, 1910
CLOSE 1911. OKAY. AND WHO WAS
THE GOVERNOR IN 1911? OH MY
GOODNESS, HIRAM JOHNSON, HIRAM
JOHNSON, GOOD GUESS. I HAVE HELP
FROM THE PEANUT GALLERY. OKAY
WHICH CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR HAD TO
ROW TO HIS INAUGURATION? HE HAS
A UNIVERSITY NAMED AT STANFORD.
YES. GOOD JOB. LELAND STANFORD.
IT WAS 1862, AND THERE WAS A
FLOOD. THAT'S WHY HE HAD TO ROW
TO HIS INAUGURATION. OKAY. AND
HERE'S THE LAST VERY DIFFICULT
QUESTION, WHICH SENATOR AUTHORED
A BILL REVERSING THE BALLOT
ORDER FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY,
WHERE LOCAL OFFICES APPEARED
BEFORE STATE AND FEDERAL
OFFICES. THAT'S MY FAVORITE
QUESTION. OF ALL THE QUESTIONS,
AND I HAVE TO CREDIT THE
GLENDALE CITY CLERK FOR BRINGING
ME THE IDEA TO DO THAT. AND WE
SHOULD DO IT STATEWIDE. YES.
GOOD. YOU COULD HAVE RUN THAT
BILL TO DO IT STATE. RIGHT?
WELL, WE DID WE STARTED OUT
STATEWIDE, BUT THEY IN ORDER TO
GET IT THROUGH ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS, THEY MADE ME DO LA
COUNTY. YES OKAY. SO BONUS
QUESTION. WHAT WAS THE SB NUMBER
THAT'S TOO HARD FOR ME. IT WAS
2525. SO WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE AND YOUR FUN
TRIVIA. AND ALSO I WANT TO THANK
THE STAFF AND THE PUBLIC FOR
THEIR TIME, THOUGHTS AND EFFORT
OVER THE PAST MANY MONTHS. AND I
WANT TO COMMEND THE CHAIR FOR
UPHOLDING THE TRIVIA TRADITION.
WHEN I LEAVE THIS PLACE. YOU
COULD YOU SHOULD MIX IT IN IN
YOUR HEARING SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU DOING THE TRIVIA
AND THANKING ME. I APPRECIATE
IT. YES, I MIGHT DO IT. I FIND
IT ENTERTAINING. OKAY, SO WE ARE
GOING TO NOW, LIFT THE CALL. SO
WE'LL START WITH AB 270 LIFTING
CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE AB 270.
MOTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ONE. CHAIR VOTED AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTED NO. NEWMAN
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO. AYE.
UMBERG. 4141. WE WILL KEEP THAT
ON CALL LIFT AND CALL ON FY ITEM
TWO AB EIGHT FOUR. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. CHAIR
VOTED AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTED AYE.
NEWMAN PORTANTINO PORTANTINO.
AYE. UMBERG. 5050. LIFTING CALL
ON FILE ITEM THREE AB 996.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR ZERO. CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTED AYE. NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO. AYE
UMBERG FIVE ZERO. THE VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO. LIFTING CALL ON FILE
ITEM FOUR AB 1784. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR. VICE CHAIR VOTED
AYE. NEWMAN. PORTANTINO AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE UMBERG. FIVE
ZERO VOTE IS FIVE ZERO. LIFTING
CALL ON FILE ITEM SIX AB 2724.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ONE. CHAIR VOTED AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTED NO. NEWMAN
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO. AYE.
UMBERG FOUR ONE. THAT IS FOUR
ONE. LIFTING CALL ON FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB 2803. A MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO.
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTED AYE.
MENGIBAR SEVEN. MENGIBAR AYE.
NEWMAN. PORTANTINO PORTANTINO.
AYE. UMBERG. NEWMAN A. NEWMAN.
AYE UMBERG. SIX ZERO. THAT'S SIX
ZERO. WE'LL KEEP THAT ON. CALL
LIFTING. CALL ON. FILE ITEM NINE
AB 2951. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ONE. CHAIR
VOTED AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTED NO.
MENGIBAR HOLD ON A SECOND. 11
2951 MY APOLOGIES. LIFTING CALL
ON 2951. MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED. MENGIBAR I NEWMAN A
NEWMAN. AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO. AYE. UMBERG. FIVE
ONE THAT'S FIVE ONE. WE'LL KEEP
THAT ON CALL LIFT AND CALL ON
FILE ITEM TEN AB 3123. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ONE. CHAIR
VOTED AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTED NO.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO. AYE. UMBERG. FIVE
ONE. THAT'S FIVE ONE. WE'LL KEEP
THAT ON. CALL. LIFT AND CALL ON
FILE ITEM 11 AB 3184. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTED AYE. NEWMAN
I'M SO SORRY. NEWMAN. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
UMBERG SIX ZERO. ALL RIGHT,
THAT'S SIX ZERO. WE'LL KEEP THAT
ON. CALL LIFT AND CALL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM INCLUDES
AB 2631. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO. CHAIR. VICE CHAIR VOTED
AYE NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO. AYE
UMBERG SIX ZERO OKAY. SIX ZERO.
WE WILL KEEP THAT ON CALL. I'M
GOING TO GO BACK FOR NEWMAN.
OKAY. LET'S JUST GO FOR A RECESS
FOR. WE WILL GO INTO A BRIEF
RECESS AND THEN COME RIGHT BACK.
WE ARE LIFTING THE CALL ON THE
ITEMS ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS. SO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL LIFTING
CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE AB 270.
MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTES
FOR ONE. CHAIR VOTED AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTED NO. NEWMAN Ã
NEWMAN. AYE FIVE ONE. AYE OKAY,
WELL HOLD ON, WE'RE STILL ON THE
FIRST BILL, SO YOU CAN VOTE ON
THIS ONE IF YOU WANT TO FILE
ITEM ONE AB 270. YES I WILL.
NEXT EVAN. NEXT MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED. GO AHEAD.
UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG. AYE SIX ONE
OKAY. SO AB 270 IS SIX ONE AND
IT'S OUT LIFTING CALL ON FILE
ITEM TWO AB 884. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTES FIVE ZERO. CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTED AYE.
NEWMAN. NICE. NEWMAN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG AYE. 707070
AND IT IS OUT LIFTING CALL ON AB
9965. ITEM THREE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTED AYE. NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. UMBERG AYE. OKAY.
CAN YOU DO SOMEBODY MOVED IT.
NO. NOBODY DID. NOBODY MOVED THE
EMOTION SUPPORT. YEAH. FILE ITEM
370. IT'S OUT. LIFT AND CALL ON
FILE ITEM FOR AB 1784. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTES FIVE ZERO. CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTED AYE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. 7070. IT'S OUT
LIFTING CALL ON AB, FILE ITEM
SIX AB 2724. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ONE. CHAIR
VOTED AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTED NO.
NEWMAN HI. NEWMAN. AYE.
PORTANTINO APOLOGIES. UMBERG.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE SIX ONE. SIX
ONE. IT'S OUT. LIFTING CALL ON
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB 2803. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO. CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTED AYE. UMBERG
AYE. UMBERG AYE. 7070. IT'S OUT.
NUMBER EIGHT.
OKAY. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON AB
2911? SEEING NONE, WE WILL MOVE
ON TO. ITEM 2951. LIFTING CALL
ON FILE ITEM NINE, AB 2951.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE ONE. CHAIR VOTED AYE.
VICE CHAIR VOTED NO. UMBERG AYE.
UMBERG. AYE 6161. IT IS OUT
LIFTING CALL ON FILE ITEM TEN AB
3123. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ONE. CHAIR VOTED AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTED NO. UMBERG. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE 6161. IT IS. OUT.
LIFTING CALL ON ITEM 11 AB 3184.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX ZERO. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTED AYE. UMBERG AYE. UMBERG.
AYE SEVEN. IT'S SEVEN ZERO. THAT
IS OUT. WE'RE NOW ON TO AB 3239.
IS THERE A MOTION ON THAT?
SEEING NONE. WE WILL MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR LIFT AND CALL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM
INCLUDES AB 2631. CURRENT VOTES
SIX ZERO. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTED I UMBERG AYE UMBERG. AYE
OKAY. THANK YOU. AND FOR A LACK
OF A MOTION, BOTH AB 3239 AND AB
2911 ARE HELD IN COMMITTEE.
IT DIDN'T FAIL, SO THERE'S
NOTHING TO RECONSIDER. BUT YOU
CAN SEEK A RULE WAIVER IN A
FUTURE HEARING. OKAY. WE ARE
OFFICIALLY ADJOURNED.